thank you
hey everyone welcome to another video by
simply learn in this video python data
visualization tutorial we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
data visualization in Python
data visualization is the field of
representing data that you already have
in a visual form which makes it easier
for both you
and the user to understand it
python has mainly three main libraries
which help in data visualization
in this tutorial we will teach you
everything that you need to know about
these three different libraries and how
you can use them to visualize your data
better
to begin we will start with the
matplotlib library we will explain
matplotlib to you teach you about the
different types of plots and how to plot
different graphs and sub graphs in
matplotlib
we will also look at how you can include
graph parameters like titles Legends and
labels into your matplotlib graphs
then we will move on to c bond
we will explain what is c bond to you
and then understand python c bond better
with the help of a Hands-On demo feel
free to follow along with it
and finally we will take a look at the
bokeh library offered by python which is
used to make interactive graphs in
Python
we will explain different graphs like
scatter charts line charts pie charts
histograms bar plots
Etc in bokeh and how you can Implement
them and make them user friendly and
Interactive
and finally we will take a look at the
layout function in Python which is used
to make interactive web interfaces
so let's get started we're going to
study
so what's in it for you what is matplot
Library types of plots plotting graphs
and sub graphs adding a graph inside a
graph graph parameters title label
Legend line graphs line types color and
transparency canvas grid and axes range
2D plots scatter step bar fill between
radar chart histogram Contour image 3D
surface image and then we'll hit a
practice example pie chart
so let's start with what is matplot
library matplot library is an open
source drawing Library which supports
Rich drawing types it is used to draw 2D
and 3D graphics and there are so many
packages in the matplot library we're
going to cover the basics and there are
so many packages that sit on top of the
matplight library that we can't even
cover them all today but we'll hit the
main one so that you have a good
understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
Library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy I
use a lot of histograms in my stuff a
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph let's start plotting them and
to do this I'm going to be using Jupiter
notebook you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the Jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our Jupiter notebook
which opens up in this case I'm using
Google Chrome you can go up here to New
and we'll create a new Python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials I usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up Jupiter and Anaconda I myself use
Jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at what let's see what that looks
like you can see your anaconda Navigator
if you install it it will automatically
install the jupyter notebook but it also
installs a lot of other things I know
some people like the QT console for
doing python or spider I've never used
them I actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then I use the
Jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while I'm
programming and even simple script in
Python I'll take it from the Jupiter
notebook and then do a save as you can
always go under file and you can
download as a Python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the IPython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here let's go ahead and put
matplot Library tutorial and I'm going
to turn this cell into a markdown so it
doesn't actually run it
but you can see it has a nice little
title there that's all Jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library let's
import
High Lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pylab and the version let's go
ahead and run this so we're going to
import our pylab module from the matplot
library and we find out that we're in
version
1.15.1 always important to note the
version you're in probably I was reading
an article that said the number one
thing that python programmers struggle
with is remembering what version they're
working in and making sure that they're
going from one platform to the other
with the same version and if we're going
to graph things I think we need some
data to graph so we're going to import
numpy as NP now if you're not familiar
with numpy definitely go back and check
out our numpy tutorial there's so many
different things you can do with it
dealing with reshaping the data and
creating the data we're just going to
use it to create some data for us and
there is a lot of ways to create data
but we're going to use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some Y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times X plus two
and let's just take a look we're going
to print X and print
y let me go ahead and run this and let's
see we got going on here so we have our
x coordinates which is 0 0.4.83
Etc and you can look at this as an X Y
plot so we have 0 we have two and we
have 0.416 we have 2.17 and just as a
quick reminder we're going to do print
in prax comma y dot reshape 25 comma two
and the reason I want to do this is I
want to show you something here a lot of
times a program returns X comma Y and
it's an array of X comma y x comma y x
comma Y and so when you're working with
the pi plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if I start off with pairs like
this I can reshape them if I know
there's 25 pairs in there I can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
I'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25. and if I run that you'll see I
end up with the same output as the X Y
the two different arrays in here
and this is important that we want X and
Y separate again that's all numpy stuff
but it's important to understand that
this is a format that matplot Library
works with it works with an array of x's
and they should match your array of y's
so each one has 25 different entities in
it and then for our basic plotting of
this data it only takes one command to
draw graph of this data and so we use
our from up here we imported pylab we
take our PI lab and the keynet lender
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our Y
coordinates and we'll throw in R and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's B for
blue we have a lot of fun yellow hard to
see yellow there we go but we'll go
ahead and stick with red run and when
you're doing presentations with these
try to be consistent you know if the
business and the shareholders send you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
you use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around and every time
one graph has red for loss and one graph
has blue for loss it gets really
confusing so make sure you're consistent
in your graphs and your coloring and
something to know because we're going to
cover this in a minute this is your
canvas size so we have a canvas here and
what we're going to do next is we're
going to look at sub graphs okay so
let's take our PI lab and create a sub
plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the matplot library
I'm not sending when I do this this is
my drawing canvas the pi lab so once
I've imported the pylab I'm drawing my
images on there very important to know
and with the subplot we're going to give
it some different values and we're going
to represent by rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row second column and
the index is like you can stack your
graphs and things like that we don't
worry too much about indexes but rows
and columns we want to go ahead and use
Row one and column two and if we're
going to have one object we should
probably have two but before we do that
we have to plot data onto the subplot so
the order is very important and we're
going to stick with our X comma Y and
let's do this we're going to add in a
third parameter here remember we did Red
we're going to add shorthand dash dash
for dashed lines so this this plots the
data into Row 1 column two and if we're
going to do that let's do another one
pilab dot subplot and if we're going to
do Row one let's do column two and index
two
and this time we're going to add G for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pylab subplot
here we go all right lab we gotta go
ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of X Y we want y comma X
Oops I messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells that the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that and you'll see it takes this
canvas splits it in two and now we have
two different graphs and we have the red
one with dashed lines and we have the
green one which is has little stars
going up and if we take this and let's
just um just for fun let's change this
and run that with an index of one it
puts them both on the same index it also
gives me a warning because it's a
strange way of doing two subplots
there's this depreciated there's another
way to do it but most people just ignore
that warning because it's not going to
go away anytime soon now that's using
the same setup what happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
I didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together it can cause us some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where I made some changes I said row two
and look what happens when I change to
column two so I now have Row 2 column
two index two I squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers so you get
a handle on them because
you know we get repeated 164 times
according to Cambridge University if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where here we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right I hope
they hit the wrong one that's why let's
go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so I
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
it gives us that warning and you can see
we now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's next look at operator
description and we'll go ahead and turn
this cell into a markdown and run that
so it looks nice so fig and remember I
talked about the canvas earlier I
briefly mentioned it we're going to look
a little bit more at the canvas later on
but that's what the figure is FID we're
going to add axes so we're going to
initialize a subplot add the subplot in
rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this that you can
do let's look at that code and see
exactly what's going on and I want you
to notice that there's fig which is the
actual canvas in the matplot library and
ax is commonly used to refer to the
subplots so we're creating subplots
you'll see ax equals PLT subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import Pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as PLT
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
PLT just like pandas's PD and numpy
array is NP certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but I would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above with the
pi lab but with the PLT so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes but we're going to do the
same plot as we did before and we'll
call it fig and we're going to set that
equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or our canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
Left Right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one and so we can go
ahead and I'm just going to put some
stuff in there I got 0.5
0.1.8.8 so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
50 percent 10 80 80 percent but it's a
control it's going to control your left
and your right along with the width and
the height so the width and the height
we're going to use 80 percent and we're
going to have like a little indent on
the left and the right and this would
look familiar from above xcs.plot X
comma Y and then let's give it a color
how about red since we're recreating the
same graph let's keep it uniform oops
and it helps if I use a ax i s instead
of axes I don't know where that came
from but this looks identical to the one
we had up above so here's our axis plot
X comma y of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot X
comma Y and again we can draw Sub graphs
we put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different notation here we have fig
comma axes equal PLT Dot subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows we're going to do one row
in columns equals two so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create Row one column two and so axes
is an array of information so we can
simply do
four so let's do X in axes
and this will now look familiar X Dot
Plot we're going to do X comma y we'll
go ahead and make it red keep everything
looking the same remember nice uniform
graphs everything looks the same and if
we go ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you'll
see we'll have three on there and let's
see if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get into tribute there because
it's trying to scrunch everything
together so it does have a limit how
much stuff you can put in one small
space that's important to know you can
fix that by changing the canvas size
which we'll look at in just a minute and
there's other ways to change it on here
but here we go we can do in rows two and
columns equals one you can see two nice
images right above each other we'll go
back to the original one row two columns
side by side left to right and we can
also draw a picture or graph inside
another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation so
let's have a fig create another figure
so we're going to start over again with
our canvas we set that equal to
plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier and this here similar
numbers we used before saying how big
this axis is this figure in the axis is
so this is going to be the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3 and if we're going to do this
they need data on them so let's go ahead
and plot some data on our axis so axis1
Dot Plot and we'll make this simply X
comma y comma make it red and then let's
go axis 2 Dot Plot and let's reverse
them y comma X comma green there we go
doing what I told you not to do you
shouldn't be swapping axes around and
plotting your data in five different
directions because it's confusing let's
go ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the
0.2.5.4.3 and let me just grab The
annotation for that that's left right
width and height so we have in here that
this is going to be left right so here's
our left is point one n 0.5 and we you
know what let's just play with this a
little bit what happens when I change
this to 0.1 it moves it way over to the
left so there's our 0.1 so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2 0.5 is the left
so that's the right so see what happens
when we do point oh let's make this
point one that actually is they had it
down uh left right I thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this point three also and that is the
width and then of course there's the
height we can make that really tiny
actually let's do 0.2 and let's run that
and you can see it changes the height on
there let me make it even smaller 0.2 by
0.2 and as you can see you can get stuck
playing with this to make it look just
right it could sometimes take a little
bit certainly once you have the settings
if you're doing a presentation you try
to keep it uniform unless it doesn't
make sense for the graph you're working
on try to keep the same color as the
same position and the same look and feel
and I mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
I just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at and what we can do is we can
change the figure size to 16 by nine and
let me run that and show you what that
looks like so it fills the whole screen
and then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this we can set the DPI
to 300 run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality I would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever I'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there
can go a lot higher too but keep in mind
the higher you get the more memory it
takes and the more lag time and the more
resources you use so usually 300 is a
good solid number to use in your dots
per inch and you can see a drill These
are nice it draws a nice large canvas
here which is 16 by nine and then the
DPI is 300 on here so it's a little
higher quality and just out of curiosity
I wonder how long it takes to draw
something double that size 600 and you
can see here we're at 600 DPI it's going
to take a while there it goes just
because it's utilizing a lot more
graphics on there and let me just go
back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100 you're not going to see a
difference on this because it is web
based Graphics are pretty low and up
here you saw I did this with the plot
figure this works the same if I do
figure axis subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
plot
X comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our axes on the subplot on here
with the fixed size and the DPI let me
take this all out let me just
move all that real quick run it again
there we go now we're back to our
original figure and let's look at some
of the other things you can do with this
one of the things we do is we can set a
title for the axis so axis set title
you'll see right here since I put this
on the axis it's the main title for the
whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our X
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it X and Y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
X label and Y label whoops where did
they go and it turns out in this
environment that you have to put it
before the title so let me go ahead and
put it before the title and there's our
x y and we run that and of course we can
also do upper size a little bit so you
can see what's going on a little better
so here we have X label X if you come
down here you'll see our X label and our
y label we can of course change this to
X
label you can change this to y
and be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our X label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do
more thing on here we have a thing
called The Legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax Legend label
one label two up here that's the format
for it but let's go down here and
actually use it I'm going to do two
different plots we're going to have axes
plot X by x times x squared and X cubed
and if I run this you'll see it puts two
nice graphs on the setup on there but
it's nice to have a legend telling you
what's going on so for the legend we can
actually do axes since we have the two
plots Legend and on here we've created
an array and we have y equals x squared
Y equals X cubed you can actually put
this as whatever you want those are just
strings and then location two and let's
go ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and you can see it puts a
nice Legend on the upper left hand
corner location two we can do location
three and run it and it drops it down to
the bottom
one I can't remember where that's at
there we go upper right so each one of
these is a number that refers to the
different locations on the screen zero
kind of have to play with them or look
them up to remember where they're at but
they do work it just kind of moves
around depending on where you want your
Legend data on there so on this section
we cover the title the graph the Y
labels and legends this is we're getting
into some starting to look really fancy
here so we now have something we can
actually put out you'll see the title of
the graph looks a little fuzzy so I
might in a web setup put the DPI up a
couple notches maybe put it at 200 100
might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots DPI equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like so you
can see it now is a lot clearer it's
also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
DPI dots per inch so the next section is
let's look at some graph features we're
going to look at line color transparency
size and a few more things on here and
oops I forgot the main title so we have
our figure and our axes equals our plot
and subplots and I'll go ahead and do a
DPI equals 150 so the graph comes out
nice and large and easy for you to see
let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do X by X plus one so it's
going to be a straight line plot
X Plus X plus two
and axes Dot Plot
x x
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it uh located data and putting your
lines on there between the nearest
neighbors there we go so it draws a nice
little graph with three lines on it one
of the things we can do is we can
control the alpha on this oops and you
can actually see the when they did these
lines it automatically pulls in
different colors for your setup so
there's some automatic automatic things
going on in there and a lot of times we
do that comma R but we're going to do
color equals red another notation on
here let's go ahead and run this now we
have a bright red line down there and
with the matplot library you're not
limited to Red you can also use the one
of many different color references as
you see here with the pound sign
1155dd which just is just blue and we
could do the same thing with another
color on here which it turns out to be
green that can just as easily do this
green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what I want to do is I want to
make this we're going to say What's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when I
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's Square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because I plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no Alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this Alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue is kind of
light blue now you can see how the two
colors add together you get almost a
purple on there so I can clearly see
where the red crosses the blue line and
then the green just blanks it over
because I didn't do any opaqueness no
Alpha
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better and
we're going to do this 0.5 and we'll run
that oops I Did equals 0.5 let me go
ahead and run that and so you can see
right here now you can easily see the
red line how it crosses the green and
the blue down here and if we want to we
can do this as the default is one is
solid so we can change this all to 0.8
let me just do that oops 58 eight there
we go run up so it must have hit a wrong
button there let me try that again I
actually get rid of a bracket and let's
go ahead and run that and we come down
here and look at this you can still see
where it passes behind them but the
green dominates and the blue dominates
because we're now at eighty percent
instead of 50 percent when you can do
less that's kind of fun although at some
point the lanes kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know Let's do let's try DPI 100 and
see what that looks like on my screen
equals 100 and we'll go ahead and just
take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just so you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if I run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what I want to do
is I want to do the line width
width equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a 0.5 a one
our 1.5 and 2 which is twice the width
of the one and if we're going to do
different sizes we had different colors
we had our Alpha scheme let's take this
whole thing here let's paste it down
here and do another one but instead of
line width let's look at Styles and
something to note here you can actually
abbreviate this with LW so line width
can also be Point let's just do
everything point two and let's set up a
line style we do the first one dashes
and let me just paste that down here so
I'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot we'll just do the
dash dot here and a colon here there we
go and there's a lot of different
options we'll look at a few more as we
go down for different ways of
highlighting data but when you look at
this we have everything as a line width
of two and now we have a straight line
we have a dashed line or a dot dash and
a dot dot dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did X plus two X plus four
so it goes right on the top and do color
black line with 1.5 so it's a smaller
line and we're going to take the line
and we're going to set dashes so look
I've changed some of the notation here
for my line and my X plot so I can set
my line comma equal to X plot and then I
can change the line settings this way
and when I run this let me run that on
here you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are buried in Link
in Link in this case they alternate
between a short Dash and a long Dash and
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this and let's paste
this down here I'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from 10 to 3 and
we're going to change this one from 15
to to 4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because I forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when I change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
3 you can see now we have the dashes of
five let's see I'm going to guess this
is a dash is a five skip ten dashes of
15 skip 3 and then it goes back to the
beginning dashes five dashes skip 10 15
dashes skip three and of course the last
one we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because I'm
using two sets of ten or if I did
something like this and changed it to 30
it really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of four let's go let's put 30 here also
30 by 30 there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're gonna here's our plot
we started with with the X Plus One X
plus two X plus three and did it in Blue
on this one's three or four different
blue lines and this property we want to
add the actual plots so you can see
where the plots are on the graph and for
that we might have marker equals o and
if we run this you'll see it puts a DOT
for each of these and there's 25 dots
because we have 25 x values so we
actually have zero in each of the
different values of X Y are then plotted
here with the dots and we don't want to
just limit ourselves to dots
can also do plus sign that's another
option dots is most common I'll actually
like the dots the best if we do the plus
signings here puts a nice crosshairs or
plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
and I think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh the number one
so if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks and let's take
oh let's just go with the o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some of the stuff we're going to
do here on just a second let's do Marker
size equals two
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here and this is
interesting because it said two I
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
DPI and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers all right
then let's take our Square on here
and we'll do we have marker size we also
have marker face we'll set that equal to
Red of course we let me take change the
so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have missed typed something
on here and I did is marker face color
equals red and so when I run that you
can now see I have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these come down here
we'll make this instead of this let's
make this plus seven and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color equals and we'll do
what green just because there we go run
very hard to actually see what's going
on there still 25 dots that kind of
overlap as you can see they print them
over each other and of course if we
really wanted to make it look horrible
we could just make that really huge
generally though you'd want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you start to see the face on there
around four and maybe on eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show on display so
we've covered a lot of stuff here as far
as our lines we've covered opaque with
our Alpha setting on there give us some
nice pastels you can see how they
overlap and how they cross over we
covered the line width different size on
there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals you can
bring this down here also to the markers
and then we added markers in just
entered a circle a plus sign the square
a little tick which uses a one then we
had a marker size and a marker color
face and we combine those you see we get
a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
from someplace up here I'd have to find
it we use the actual number for the
color as opposed to I changed them to
red and blue so you get very precise on
the color if you have very specific
color set that you need to match your
website or whatever you're working on
all of those are tools in the matplot
library so we have one more piece to
formatting the graph so we want to show
you and then we have two big sections
we're going to go over the different
graphs that they have along with a
challenge problem so let's go in the
last section we're going to look at is
limits we're going to limit our data so
this first parameter is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size a 10
comma five this would all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axis out of two
and we're going to plot x x squared x x
cubed line width two so we're going to
go ahead and just plot two graphs right
on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to True one here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
are two plots with the x value going
across and I'm going to do something
similar and by the ways you can just if
you look at it you can see the Grid on
there that's all that is easier to spot
the data going across we're going to
take the same data for axes one so we
have our plot of x x squared x and x
cubed line with two and this time we're
going to take our axes 1 and do y limit
that's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
zero comma 60. I'm just making these
numbers up the guys in the back actually
made them up I'm just using their
numbers and we're going to set the x
limit
and let's set the x limit as don't
forget our brackets there 2 comma 5. so
it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the Y
limit 0 to 60. so we're looking at just
the lower part of this curve here up to
here and we have the X limit two to five
so that starts right here at 2 and you
can see very different graphs this is
kind of nice because you could actually
put one of these on top of the other if
you wanted to draw Focus to one part of
a graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the Grid in there
oops I guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if I change it to one so in this case it
might not be the order I wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing in
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data so let's start
looking at some other 2D graphs and make
this cell a markdown so we run it as a
nice pretty title to it and let's go
ahead and create some data with an NP
array we'll do 0 to 5 on here there we
go and let's look at four common graphs
we'll put them side by side so we'll do
a figure our axis equals plot subplots
one four columns and then figure size
hopefully will fit nicely on here it
seems to do a pretty good on here and
I'll go and just run that since we're in
there run you'll see I have my four
blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero the
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our in
we can do X or nope there
and let's go ahead and do axis set title
scatter up already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable X X Plus let's
throw some Randomness in here use these
Scatter Plots are have a lot of random
numbers connected to them that's why
they do them on there and so the bigger
the X gets the bigger the randomness so
0.25 times the randomness and what we
should end up down here is with the
scatter plot and you can see as you go
up it just kind of has some random
numbers and moves up and down the line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker this is plotting basically just
the marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
X is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time I'll use our n value
instead of X we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times two or N squared n times 2 N
squared line width equals two and if we
run that it creates a nice Step Up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step plot let's do a bar
plot
and we'll use the same formula in N
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
Alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is let's see what that
looks like on there so we have some nice
you can see here a nice bar plot it
should look very similar to the step
plot but color it in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that everything you really can't
see the shift on here because that's
actually the default on this but these
are common settings for the bar graph
let me just put them back in there there
we go alignment center and Alpha now I
can't say I have used the step craft
very much there's certain other certain
I guess domains of expertise that
require a step graph but the scatter
plot and the bar graph very common
especially the bar graph and we'll look
at histograms here in just a minute so I
use histograms a lot especially in data
science but this is nice if you have
very concrete objects somebody how many
people are wearing yellow hats that kind
of thing but if we're going to do that
let's go ahead and do the last one which
I see a lot more in the Sciences
certainly using the data science but
more like for mapping like cell
publication on solar flares and they're
discussing the energy and so filling in
the graph gives it a very different look
so we're going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's filled between but with a
underscore between and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and Alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two-dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest I've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science I have to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axes and the figure and with
this this actually creates our all this
let's run it so you can see what it
creates it creates a nice looks like
you're on a submarine and you're
tracking The Hunt for Red October or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates 0 0.6.6 has to
do with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here I'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data T equals NP line space
and this is 0 to 2 times NP times pi so
if you remember that is the distance
across and we're going to generate a
hundred points so this is just a thing
of data we're putting together let me
simply do an ax Dot Plot and in this
case let's do T comma T which would be a
diagonal line and a regular chart and
we'll give it a nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of T times 0.5 there we go and
you can see it slightly Alters the way
it spirals out we could do T times two
it spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun like I said I've
never used a radar chart it's a column
but you can always think of radar under
submarine kind of looks like one of
those or on an airplane and none of this
would be complete if we didn't discuss
histograms oh my gosh do I use a
histogram so much and we'll use our
numpy that we have set as NP to generate
oh looks like we have a hundred thousand
variables we're going to set equal to n
and of course we create our figure and
our axes from subplots one two figure
size 12 14. so we're going to look at
two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply hit
for histogram and we'll just go ahead
and put in our n in there and let me run
this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data from 1000 random arrays it looks
like they're mostly between minus four
and four and then it adds up each one it
says I'm 0 you have 35
000 that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have 20 000 that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus two and well it looks
like one and minus two and somewhere
between zero and one there's thirty
thousand numbers so all this is saying
is this is how common these variables
are and this gives you this is a point
in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your rate just like you did on
the other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram and all it is is a histogram
let me just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bends equal 50. and I really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has the printed data out
for us and here's our whoops I must have
missed oh there we go it doesn't help
that I put it over the old one there we
go okay so now you have your default
histogram and now we have a cumulative
histogram and we should have 50 steps in
there and let's just find out if that's
true not So Much by counting them I'm
not going to count them if you want to
you can count them let's just change it
to 10 and see what happens and we see
here we have now 10 counts of that
we'd set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before I
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run and so now it
should look almost identical and it does
and then we can put the cumulative back
in see what that looks like with the
cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look wait it shifts it all to
the right no it doesn't actually shift
it to the right it's cumulative so it's
a total of the different currencies and
so what that means is like if you
consider this like for the year of
rainfall we have like day one you had a
little bit of rain day two we have more
rain and so if you look at the number
this is a hundred thousand thirty five
thousand so it's a cumulative detail the
histogram the currents as it grows and
rainfall is a good one because that
would be a cumulative histogram of how
much rain occurred throughout the year
and we're going to look at two more
graphs we've already looked at a bunch
of them we looked at our radar graph
we've looked at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps just put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map we
need to go ahead and create data for it
and if you have Contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array and we'll import
matplot.cm and that's your color Maps so
you have all these different color maps
you can look at there's like hundreds of
color Maps so if you don't want to do
your own color you need to do your own
color map they're pretty diverse and of
course our PLT we're going to our PI
plot and to generate our different data
we're going to create a Delta 0.025 and
we'll start with X and we're going to
create an array between -3 and 3 and
Delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our X Y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for our Z1 we'll do a Z2
so we have two different areas and Z
equals z of one minus Z2 times 2. so
we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our X from our PLT subplots we're
going to create the variable Cs and this
is going to be our Contour so right here
CS is our Contour surface and we're
feeding it X Y and Z if you remember X Y
we created as our X and Y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print X and let's print Y and I always
like to do this when I'm working with
something this either is really
complicated in this case is what we're
looking at or you don't understand yet
so we've created a mesh grid we have x y
and when we're done with this we end up
with here's our X
and this set of values in our y so those
are X and Y coordinates and then we've
also created Z based on our X and Y so
we have x capital x capital Y and
capital Z is our three components X and
Y being the coordinates well Z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our X Y and Z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do an title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represents
zero maybe that's sea level and then
moving on up you have your Contours of
0.5 and minus one and different setups
little Hills I guess if it's minus
that's like a pit so I guess you're
going down into a pit at minus five and
minus one but on the other side you can
see you're going up in levels so here's
a mountain top and here's like a basin
of some kind and in data science this
could represent a lot of things this
could also be representing two different
values and maybe profits and loss I
don't know if I'd ever really do that as
a contour map but I'm sure you can be
creative and find something fun to do
with a contour map and then we're going
to look at one last map which is the 3D
map and those are can be really
important as a final product because
they can show so much of additional
information that you can't fit on
two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3D image and so we're
going to import from our MPL toolkits
the implant 3D and the axis 3D we're
going to import axis 3D this is what's
going to let us work with the 3D image
and this should look familiar we're
going to create another figure just like
we did before figure size 14 by 6. it's
a good fit on the screen we'll go ahead
and run that so we have our figure and
let's go ahead and take our X and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
subplot that should also be familiar
from earlier and we're going to work
with this sets the settings for the
projection we're going to use one two
one projection 3D and we'll see what
that looks like in just a minute and we
just created some three-dimensional data
here before where we had X Y and Z
capital X Y and Z so we're going to
reuse that data we're just going to use
that since this also this is also a
three-dimensional image so let's use
that for a three-dimensional graph and
we simply do ax plot underscore
surface and a capital x capital y
capital Z so there's our data coming in
and we're going to add some settings in
here we're going to do R stride 4 C
stride four and line width 0. I'll show
you what that is here in just a minute
let's go ahead and run that so we can
see our graph and of course it helps if
I don't add an extra comma in there and
you can see it generates this really
beautiful three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the C stride four
and the projection 3D projection 3D is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3D graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these I'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to 1.
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead and you're
going to see how it starts reshaping the
size and how it fits on the screen and
we'll change the first one to two and
we'll run that one and again it's
changed the dimensions and the size and
how it fits on here play with these
numbers to get a nice look and feel for
it and part of it is the Tilt and the
angle
I'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size and
outfits on the canvas but we'll leave it
at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what that we're talking about here this
is column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole setup on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and I'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat map
you might see that is kind of starting
to lose ground as far as a common
reference but there sure are a lot of
people still talking about heat Maps
what is a heat map well it is simply a
color map that's all it is so if you
ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into let me go
back up here here we go this one has
different colors for the different
values a lot of times you'll use like
instead of X and Y you might do a heat
map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3D image into nice
colors represented by a heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type marked down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a Python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and I'll just throw in
our import our matplot library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have Java PHP JavaScript c-sharp C
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent Java 17.6 and
I don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled my guess is that they might
have just been made up because I don't
know if Python's really that much more
popular than the other ones maybe
specific to data science because
Python's very popular in data science
right now because it has so many options
the only other program that's highly
used and exclusively for data science is
R so Python's big and python also does a
lot more it's a full programming
language where R is primarily for data
science they didn't put R in here so we
have python we have Java we have our PHP
can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and I did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors I'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so I'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that it could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is 0.1 and then
zero zero zero zero zero point one when
we put this in here under the explode in
the plot it will actually push that
square out so it's a really cool feature
to highlight certain information on a
pie chart
and this is simply PLT dot pi and we're
plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras I talked about
explode where we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
Auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python setup on there
and that's just going to put the value
on the pi slice and then we're going to
add Shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3D look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
that's pushed out there's our shadow a
3d effect and then we started at 140. we
could also rotate this let's just do
this angle 90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue Pi slices moved up a
little bit we could actually do actually
let's just take the whole starting
triangle out and run he'll default to
zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that to appear on the
left because people read left to right
and so it draws a focus onto in this
case Python and how great python is I'm
a little biased we're teaching a Python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at Python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library.pi plot
setup and if you go underneath there the
different functions on there you can
look this up on their website you'll see
a full list and this is why it's so
important to go through a tutorial like
this because this list is just so
massive I'm trying to figure out like
here's our bar plot there's a bar H you
can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover C labels a totally
different kind of for your Contour plot
you can set up in there if you go down
here we have our figures we used on
there we showed you the basics how to do
the figure you'll see some closer
references on those there's a histogram
down here hist there's also the hist 2D
makes a 2d histogram plot H lines all of
this these are all the different
commands that are underneath of here and
you can see it's pretty extensive we've
covered all the basic ones so that you
know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library we
will learn how to visualize data and
draw insights with different charts and
graphs using the seabon library
these visualizations are often referred
to as plots in Python
so what is c bond in Python the c bond
library in Python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlab
data visualization Library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis
using c bond you can create interactive
plots to answer specific questions about
your data
it helps you find Trends in your data
that you can't notice just by looking at
the data
now to understand the C1 library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we will be
using two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cast data set
and the second is the popular Iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and rename the notebook I'll say
C bone
demo
will rename it
all right
you can see I have the first two cells
already filled in so while working on an
exploratory data analysis project using
python you will need numpy pandas
macplotlib and c-bond libraries for data
manipulation and visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
I've already written import numpy as NP
pandas SPD
matplotlib.pi plot splt C bonus SNS
all right so I'll hit shift enter to run
this first cell
all right
Now using the read underscore CSV
function that is present in the pandas
Library I am importing my data set that
is empty cars I'll tell you what empty
cars is about this is a CSP data set and
here I have given the location where my
data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars data frame
for that I'm using the head function if
I run it
okay you can see here it has given me
the first five rows the index starts
from 0 till 4 so total five rows of
information and
you can see these are the columns that
are present in the empty cast data set
the first is the
model of the car
now just let me give you a background
about this data set
so the data is taken from the 1974 Motor
Trend Us magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the First Column as the
model of the car and then we have MPG
which is miles per gallon
then we have C by L which stands for the
number of cylinders in the vehicle or
the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in cubic inches so these all values are
in cubic inches
after that we have HP which is cross
horsepower
then we have something called as drat
which is basically the rear axle ratio
then we have WT which is the
weight of the
car in pounds
so think of it as weight multiplied by
1000 pounds
all right and then we have q SEC which
is one fourth mile time this is a
measure for acceleration then we have
something called as vs this is
the type of engine for each of the
vehicles so 0 stands for v-shaped engine
and one stands for straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so 0 is for
automatic transmission and one is for
manual transmission
then we have the number of forward gears
present in the vehicle and then we have
something called as carb or carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying a spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and Air
all right
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index data type column data types
then we have the information about
non-known values and memory usage
so I'll write my data frame name which
is empty cars
dot I am going to use the info function
let's run it and here you can see we
have
all the columns there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so data about 32
cars
then here you can see the date types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me just print the shape of the data
frame that will give you the number of
rows and columns present I'll use this
shape attribute
you can see here there are total 32 rows
and 12 columns in my data set now the c
bond Library provides a range of
plotting functions that meets the
visualization and Analysis of data
easier
so we'll cover some of the crucial plots
that are available in cball
so let's start with a bar plot
I'll give a
comment as
bar plot
now
first understand what a bar plot is so a
bar plot gives an estimate of the
central tendency of a numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle it
provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars now to build this plot you
usually choose a categorical column in
the x axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so
we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
I'll declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then I'll use SNS
which is for the c bond Library
I'll say SNS Dot followed by my bar plot
function
and inside the function
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket using
quotation I'll give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my x
axis and for y axis I'll say
my data frame name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display I'm going to use the
matte plotly function I'll say PLT dot
show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have vehicles with 4 6
or 8 cylinders and on the y-axis you can
see the miles per gallon now what
essentially this graph tells us is that
when the number of cylinders in the
vehicle increases my miles per gallon
MPG for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these black lines so
these lines indicate the uncertainty
around the estimate using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another way now we
will exclusively Define the X and Y axis
columns and also pass the name of the
data frame using the data argument let
me show you how to do it
I'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
I am going to exclusively Define my x
axis I'll say x equal to
I'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then I'll say y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write PLT dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot as the above one so this
is another way to create a bar plot now
python c bond allows the users to assign
colors to the bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that I am going to use the color
argument
so I'll say res equal to
sns. my function that is bar plot
I'll say X
equal to
cylinder
my y axis
will have
MPG
and then I'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute I'll
say
color
equal to I'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
I'm going to write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the color
argument let's say I'll make it to red
if I print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right
now C bone Library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars so if you go to
Google and search for
C bone palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
palettes provided by
C bone you can see here SNS dot color
palette and these are the
names of the palette
you can use whichever palette you want
all right
so
I'll say res equal to
sns.bar plot
we'll use our first method of
assigning
a bar plot so I'm using my data frame
empty cars and this time we are going to
change the X and Y labels let's say I'm
using
my X label as
transmission whether
automatic or manual transmission
and then in my y-axis I'll have
miles per gallon
then
I'm going to say palette
equal to
I made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set to this is the name of the palette
I'll write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission and you
can see the miles per gallon for each of
the modes of transmission if you want
you can change the palette colors let me
just copy this
I'll paste it in my new cell
and instead of set to let's see we'll
use
another palette called as Rocket
and I'm also going to alter
my X and Y labels let's see in my X
label I'll have gear
and my y label will be horsepower
if I run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors on the x-axis you have the gears
three gear 4 gear or five gear vehicle
and on the y-axis you have the
horsepower
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot so the count plot function in
the python C bone Library Returns the
count of total values for each category
using bars we will create a count plot
that Returns the total number of
vehicles for each category of cylinders
I'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so I'll start
SNS Dot
I'll use the count plot function
and I'll Define my x axis as
cylinders
my y-axis won't have any label or any
column because y-axis will only show the
count
then I am going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
let's say I'll set the
palette
to
set one
let me run it
okay there is some error let's debug the
error
says Str object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes
make sure the data frame name is without
the single quotes let's run it again
there you go
so you can see here this is a nice count
plot that shows the number of cylinders
on the x axis and on the y axis you have
the count you can see here
there are more number of vehicles that
have eight cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders
and actually you can count it as well so
you can see here there are 14 cars that
have 8 cylinders that are 11 cars that
have four cylinders and there are seven
cars that have
six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each carburetor
so for that I'm going to say
sns.
count plot
my x axis will now have
the variable carburetor
LC data equal to empty cars
and
my palette
I'll set it to
set one
let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight and you can see we have
more number of cars that have two and
four carburetors and there are very few
vehicles that have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c-bond Library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
I'll say SNS Dot
count plot
I'm going to Define my y label or the
y-axis as
gear
I'll say data equal to
empty cars and
set my
palette to
let's say rocket
let me run it
okay you see here this is a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars where
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y-axis you have the gear column
and on the x axis you have the count
so if you Mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are 12 vehicles that have 4 gears
and there are total 5 vehicles with 5
gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the Hue parameter so the Hue
parameter accepts the column name for
color encoding
now let's build a count plot that shows
the number of cars for each category of
Gears grouped by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the Hue parameter for that
I'll say
sns. count plot
in the x axis I'll have my
gear column
then I am going to pass my Hue parameter
that will have the cylinder column or
the number of cylinders for each vehicle
I'll pass my data frame
using the data argument
as empty cars and say pallet
I'll set my palette to set 1.
let's run it
if I scroll down you see here we have
account plot
on the x-axis you have three four and
five gears of the different vehicles and
for each gear you have the bars that
represent the number of cylinders
so for vehicles that have three gears we
have
majority of the vehicles Having Eight
cylinders
similarly for vehicles that have four
gears we have most of the vehicles with
four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have
one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool now moving ahead
so the seabond library supports the dist
plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg Matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here I'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
I'll say sns.
dist plot
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
MPG which is my column name
then I am going to
Define the number of bins that I want
let's say 10
and then I'll use the
color argument
and I'll see let's say G which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if I scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot so these are all
histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right now moving ahead
you can also create heat Maps using the
seabon library
so the heat Maps will let you visualize
metrics like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation Matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we'll create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty cars
data set
just give a comment as heat map
I'll say SNS and
I'll use the heat map function
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
my function called
Corr which is for correlation
then I'll say c bar
is equal to true
so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar
then I'll see
line widths
I'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go here you can see we have a
nice heat map and on the right side you
can see the color bar that starts from
minus 0.8 and goes up to plus 0.8 so
this ranges between minus 1 and plus one
and
the bars or the cube you can see that
have
a lighter color have a positive
correlation
and the ones that are
dark have a negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and MPG
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means
when the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases and this
we also had seen in our first
bar plot this one you can see here
whenever
the number of cylinders increased your
miles per gallon had decreased
and this is what has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive correlation
which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle and
the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
okay now let's move ahead
c bond scatter plot function helps you
create plots that can draw relationships
between two continuous variables so to
understand about Scatter Plots and other
plotting functions
henceforth we are going to use Iris plot
data set so let's go ahead and load the
iris flight data set I'll say Irish
equal to SNS Dot
load underscore
data set
so this Iris flight dataset is already
inbuilt into the SNS or the c-bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows from the data
set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
Supple length Supple width better length
and petal width of the three species of
flower
that is satosha
Virginia and versicolor
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different pieces of flour and
the count for each of the species of
flowers that we have in our data set
I'll say Irish
within square brackets I'll pass in the
output or the target variable that is
species and I'll use the function that
is
value underscore counts
let's run it there you go so we have
50 flowers of Sentosa type
again 50 plus of versicolor species and
then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica so there are total 150 flowers
present in our data set
all right
I will create a scatter plot to show the
relationship between Supple length and
petal length for different species of
Iris Plus
so I'll say SNS Dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis I'll
say
Supple length
column
give a comma
I'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then I'll say
data
equal to Iris
now let's run it
you can see here
this is my scatter plot between Supple
length and better length
now you can classify the different
species of flowers using the Hue
parameter as species in the function
so what I'll do is
I'm going to copy my
above
code I just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
I'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the blue dots are for satosha
the orange dots are for
C color and for virginica you have the
green dots from this scatter plot you
can see that for virginica flowers the
Supple length and the petal length are
higher than
your vertical around
satosha
and this region is completely for
satosha flowers so you can see that the
status of flowers have
lower Supple length and petal length
all right
you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will
differentiate
the different species of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
I'll say size as species
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
flowers are in green dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then we have satosha whose
sizes
large okay
now the python c bond Library lets you
visualize data using pair plots that
produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a peer
plot I'll say SNS Dot
peer plot which is the function
then I'll pass in my data frame name
that is Iris
I'll put this
Iris data frame Within
double quotes
and we'll run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be pandas data frame okay
what I'll do is I'll just remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so just wait for a while there
you go here you can see we have a nice
pair plot on the
y-axis you have the
Supple length Supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x axis
also you have the same feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
Scatter Plots now you can convert the
diagonal visuals to
KDE or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of this Scatter Plots using
the Hue parameter this makes the paired
plot easier to classify each type of
flower
so
I'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
I'll say hue
equal to
species then
I'll see
palette
equal to
set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go
so here you have the
paired plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the difference
PCS the red color dots represent satosha
floss the blue color dots represent
versicolor
and the
green color
dots represent virginica class
now if you
look at this graph you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers the reason being you can see
here
they are very well categorized and they
are separated
all the red dots present here in The
Petal length represents atosa flowers
around this range
all the blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers so out of the four
features petal width petal length Supple
width and supple length
you can take petal length as the best
feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right now
coming to LM plot function
so the LM plot function in the c bond
Library draws a linear relationship as
determined through regression for
continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
Iris flowers
I'll just give a comment here as
LM plot
I'll say SNS Dot
in the x axis we'll have
petal length
give a comma in the y-axis
I'll pass in
petal width
and I'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is Iris
let's run it
you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here is a linear
regression line
now in this LM plot you can use the Hue
parameter to differentiate between each
species of flowers and you can set
markers
for different species let me show you
how to do it
I'll say SNS Dot
LM plot
we'll say X
hazard
petal length
give a comma
I'll write y
as
petal
width
then I am going to pass the Hue
parameter
in Hue I'll see
my column as PCS
then I'll give data equal to
my data set name that is Iris and now
you can pass in
markers argument
to differentiate the different
types of laws let's say I want to
represent setosa with
dot or o
then my next species which is versicolor
should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say this Arrow
mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and the circle dots in blue color
represent satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flowers using the regression
line all right now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function
where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data the Box represents the
quartiles of the data set
the whiskers show the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their Supple width
I'll just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our c bond
demo
I'll say sns.box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y axis we'll have
supple
width
then I'll pass my data
as Iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this box plot created
at the bottom in the x axis you can see
we have
the box plot for
status of flowers
orange for vertical flowers and green
for virginica flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the Box
so this is also the median for vertical
of loss you can compare the
median sepal width for each of the
flowers from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
Supple width value for satosha flower
and this line at the bottom represents
the minimum
length of the Supple width for cetusa
Plus
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right so that brings us to the end
of this demo session on
c bond
library in Python so first we imported
our empty cars dataset
then we saw how to create a bar plot
we learned how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside bar plot
we also saw how to use the palette
attribute or the palette parameter
then we learned about
creating count plots
then we saw how to create horizontal
count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that we analyzed the other
functions
such as the scatter plot
then we had the pair plot
and we had the
LM plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris plot data set
so first we will explain what exactly
the meaning of bokeh is
then we will take a look at scatter
charts and see how we can Implement them
in bokeh
next we'll understand what line shots
are the scenarios in which they are used
and how they can be coded in Python
bokeh
then we'll move on to pie charts and
understand how data distribution can be
represented using them
next we will take a look at histograms
then we'll move on to bar plot and
understand the difference between
histograms and bar plots
we'll then take a look at area plot and
how to understand them
and then we will move on to the layout
function in bokeh which is used to make
interactive web pages
and finally we will use a data set to
understand how we can make interactive
charts in bokeh by using everything that
we've already learned in this video
so the first question that probably
comes to your mind is what exactly is
bokeh
bokeh is a python Library which is used
to make highly interactive graphs and
visualizations this is done in bokeh
using HTML and JavaScript
this makes bokeh a powerful tool for
creating projects custom charts and web
design based applications
now bokeh is a python library for
creating interactive visualizations for
modern web browsers it helps you build
beautiful Graphics ranging from simple
plots to complex dashboards with
streaming data sets with bokeh you can
create JavaScript visualizations without
writing any JavaScript yourself
this makes it a very powerful tool for
data visualization
next let's take a look at scatter charts
and how you can plot them in bokeh
now Scatter Plots are a plot of each
individual data point in the data two
variables are plotted against one
another and each data point on the
x-axis has a corresponding individually
plotted value on the y-axis as a result
the plot looks like a bunch of scattered
points
these are some examples of scatter
charts here each point on the chart
corresponds to a value on the x-axis and
its respective value on the y-axis
using Scatter Plots we can see how two
different variables correspond to each
other now let's see how we can plot
scatter charts using bokeh
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of the
necessary modules for our python project
the first module that we're going to
need is the pandas module which is used
to work on data frames
next we will also be importing the
pandas bokeh module which is used to
Implement bokeh on pandas data frames
next we will import bokeh.io which we
will use to show the various graphs that
we are plotting we will also import
bokeh dot plotting which will help us in
plotting all of the various graphs that
we're going to be looking at we'll also
import glob a module which will help us
merge our files and get them in the
required format
so the first line of code that we're
going to be writing is Panda's
underscore bokeh dot output underscore
notebook this is basically just a line
of code which will help you see your
output in the same notebook itself
now let's see how we can plot Scatter
Plots in bokeh
we already have imported the figure
function from OK dot plotting the figure
function contains most of the plots that
we want to plot such as line plots
Scatter Plots bar charts Etc so this is
what we're going to be using
the first thing that you're going to
need to do is create a figure
so how do we do that
let's create a random variable p and
this we're going to be initializing to
the figure function
now within this figure function we're
just going to add a couple of parameters
for a figure itself so let's say we want
the plot width to be equal to 400
and the plot
height to be equal to 402 we're going to
be plotting a scatter plot in the form
of a square here next we know that a
scatter plot is nothing but various
circles which are plotted on top of our
graph so that's what we're going to do
we're gonna be plotting
circles
at certain coordinates
which are going to be given by our lists
so the first coordinate is going to be
the x-axis and the next list that you're
passing in is going to represent the
y-axis coordinates so over here let's
just plot
this has 1 comma 2
3 4 and 5.
and over here let's start with four
seven these are all just random points
this is just to show you how exactly you
can plot a graph in bokeh and now let's
just say that we want the size of the
circles to be equal to 10
and the color of every Circle
to be Navy
we're also going to give a random
parameter called Alpha and equate that
to 0.5 so just act as a placeholder now
over here you've initialized your figure
function and given it certain parameters
and using this figure function you're
calling the circle attribute of it
passing in other parameters such as the
x-axis coordinates and the y axis
coordinates the size of the circle the
color of each circle and a random
parameter called Alpha so now we've
imported all of our modules and this is
how you plot a scatter chart in bokeh
the same thing can be done when you look
at the line plot all you have to do is
initialize your figure function and call
the line attribute of it pass in your
x-axis coordinates in your y-axis
coordinates maybe pass in a couple of
other parameters that are required such
as the width that you want the line to
be and the color that you want the line
to be and finally all you have to do is
show the plot this is a basic overview
of how you can use bokeh to plot grass
and here we have a line plot
so the main difference between the
scatter plot here and the line plot here
is that the line plot has various
different points which are connected to
each other with the help of a line
so again what exactly are line charts a
line chart is a chart that represents
data as a series of points which are
connected to each other with the help of
a line it is used to see Trends in our
data and track the way data changes over
a period of time
so this is the same chart that we just
plotted using bokeh right now so as you
can see so the parameters that you know
were passed in were one two three four
and five on the x-axis and three one two
six and five on the y-axis so how
exactly the line chart is plotted is
that you plot each of these points and
then you connect them or join them using
a line next let's take a look at pie
charts and how they can be implemented
in bokeh
but first what exactly is a pie chart
a pie chart is a circular chart which is
divided into slices to represent how
much of the data belongs to a certain
category
it is a quick and easy way to see the
categories in our data and the
percentage of the data set that they
represent
on the other hand you have another type
of chart called a donut chart
donut charts are like pie charts with a
hole in the center and in this hole you
can use it to represent extra data
or you can draw a pie chart within that
hole itself
so this is an example of a pie chart
using this you can easily get to know
the various categories that our data is
divided into and the percentage that
each of these categories contribute
towards our data
like over here we have a pie chart which
represents crewmates and imposters in a
game called Among Us
so using this we can just say that
around 75 percent of our data is
crewmates and 25 percent of it is
imposters
on the other hand you have a donut chart
which is almost exactly the same as the
pie chart except the middle portion is
missing values
and in this middle portion you can do
other things such as plot a pie chart
or represent other data within it
so now let's see how we can plot our PI
plots using python bokeh but first we
need to import the data that we're gonna
be using to plot all of this
so the data that we're going to be
looking at is the Among Us data among us
as you might know is a game that caused
quite a frenzy in the past two years
so the data that we're going to be
working at is the Among Us data set that
you can find on kaggle Among Us was the
new craze for people playing mobile
games that suddenly exploded in
popularity and became a hit video game
during the pandemic
now Among Us is basically a multiplayer
game where 4 to 10 players are dropped
in an alien spaceship each player has
their own role of imposter or crewmate
the task of the crewmate is to run
around the spaceship to complete various
tasks which are assigned to them and
also to not get killed by an imposter
players can be voted off the ship so
each game becomes one of survival
so let's load this data set and create
more features
so now we've imported our data set as
you can see our data set has over 2000
rows and 14 columns the First Column
that I want to show you is the user ID
column the user ID column tells us which
user the game data was collected from
now there are 14 columns the game
completed data tells us the date and
time of game completion the team tells
us if the player is an imposter or a
crewmate
the outcome tells us if the game was won
or lost
so over here this is each game that a
certain user has played user ID is used
to represent the user who has played the
game and as you can see we've collected
data from 29 different people
and the number of games that these 29
people totally have played is over 2000.
the outcome tells us whether the
user has won or lost in this game the
task completed tells us how many tasks
was completed by this user in this game
all tasks completed tells us what the
user was able to finish their tasks
murder tells us if the user was murdered
an imposter kills tells us a number of
kills by The Imposter so if the user was
not an imposter we do not have data on
how many kills was committed by The
Imposter during that particular game
that's why this column has a lot of
missing values
Game Land tells us
the total duration of the game and
ejector tells us if the player was
ejected or thrown off of the spaceship
by their fellow players
sabotage is fixed is basically the
Imposter within the game can create
sabotages and it's the crewmate's duty
to fix them
so this tells us the number of sabotages
which was fixed by this particular
crewmate
time to complete all tasks tells us the
duration taken by the crewmates to
complete all the tasks and the rant
change tells us the change in rank after
wins or losses of the game
the region
or the game code tells us the server and
the game code
now first let's just see how exactly the
data is distributed
so this tells us how many uh counts each
column has uh so as you can see here
most of them have the same number of
counts except rank change which has a
couple of missing values
unique tells us how many unique values
exist in each column
uh so obviously team there will be two
because there are only two possible
outcomes you can either be a crewmate or
you can either be an imposter outcome
also has only two unique values because
you either win a game or you lose a game
task completed has 12 different values
and this is because the
number of tasks which have been
completed probably range from 1 to 12.
all tasks completed has three values
which is yes no and missing data and the
same goes for murdered you have yes no
or missing data imposter kills tells us
how many kills the Imposter has made
so in this case
uh the more skills that the person has
made is probably nine
a game length there are 988 different
values and ejected again there are only
two values because you can either be
ejected or you can either stay in the
game
now the Top Value tells us the most
frequently occurring value and the
frequency tells us the frequencies of
all of the top values now let's create a
feature called minute and extract data
from game length
so we're going to be splitting the game
length column which is this column and
we're going to be converting it into
minutes
and then we're going to be
using that data and creating a separate
uh feature column called minutes out of
it
so let's do this
so these are the first top two values of
our minutes call of our new minutes
column uh the zeroth value is 7 because
the first
game length that you see here was of
seven minutes so all that we're doing is
that we're going to be splitting this
value which is seven minutes four
seconds and we're gonna be keeping only
the first value which is out of the
minutes the second minutes value is 16
minutes
and that corresponds to the second value
in our minutes feature variable
now let's take a look at the murdered
Golem the murdered column has yes no yes
no values and missing data set and
missing values so let's change those
we're going to be replacing no values
with not murdered yes values with
murdered and the simple Dash with
missing and we're going to be doing this
in place which basically means that this
is going to make a change to our main
data frame
so this is done let's take a look at our
data frame now
this is what our data frame looks like
we have a games length column we have a
minutes column
and we also have made changes to our
murdered column which is represented
here so now we don't have any missing
values or dashes in our murdered column
we have all of it represented as
categorical data
and this is one of the main columns that
we're going to be using to plot our PI
plots
so now let's see how we can plot a pie
chart
the first thing that we're going to be
doing is that we're gonna be getting the
total value counts in our team column
here
so we're going to be plotting a pie
chart with the help of the steam column
and we're gonna be getting the value
counts of each unique
value in the team column
so let's you can do this with the help
of the value counts function that pandas
data frames provides us with
announce that we have the value counts
of each unique value which is present in
our team column let's plot it in the
form of a pie chart
we're gonna be doing this with the help
of the plot bokeh function
and the type of chart that we want to
plot is a pie chart
let's give it a title
as
ratio of
imposters versus
crewmates
and let's run this now and this is what
your Pi plot looks like after you've
plotted it
so now the same thing can be done to
plot a donut plot the first thing that
we want to see is if there are more
crewmates or imposters murdered or not
in the game
to do this we will add two more features
angle and color which are
gonna be used in the chart
so to get angle we're going to be
importing PI from math and we're gonna
be converting our angle in the form of
radians and as for the color feature
we're going to be having three different
shades of blue
so this is basically what our murder
data frame looks like uh so over here
you have not murdered the total value
counts of which is 894 and the angle
that this gives us is 2.5
22302 and this is the corresponding
color the same goes for murdered which
is 867 values and we've converted that
into an angle in radians and given it
its own color and finally we also have
missing values of which there are 466
the angle is
1.314756 and it has its own
corresponding color
so this is a data frame that we're going
to be using to plot our donut chart
so from bouquet.transform we import
cumulative sum and the cumulative sum is
what we're going to be using to find the
start of our angle basically to find
or basically to find how much portion of
our donor chart is going to be occupied
by the angle so the donut chart can be
plotted using the angular wedge function
from figure
so the x-axis here is 0 and the y-axis
is 1 the inner radius is the radius that
you are going to be giving to the inner
smaller Circle and that we've given a
0.15 the outer radius is the radius of
the bigger Outer Circle
and the direction in which our data is
going to be plotted is in the
anti-clockwise direction
so let's run this
and this is what our donut chart looks
like
so the not murdered is this dark blue
color portion of our donut chart and
when you hold and when you hover over it
you can see how many values are present
in the not murdered column
the same goes for murdered and because
we've plotted our data in the
anti-clockwise function this is how it's
being plotted so murdered not murdered
and then finally you have the missing
values the way that you can interpret
this graph is that you can say that most
of the people were murdered during the
game but most of the data is missing so
we can't say for certain whether the
majority of the people were murdered
during the game or not because the
number of missing values can make a huge
difference and the number of people who
were not murdered and the number of
people who are murdered are very close
to each other like their total values
are very close to each other
next we will create a data frame of
sabotage as fixed and minutes and change
the column name and add T in them
so this is basically what we're doing
we've created a data frame which has the
number of sabotages fixed and the
minutes now let's just take the three
sabotages which were fixed which is 0 1
and 2 and create a data frame out of all
of these
so each of these individual data frames
just contains these individual columns
to make a simple scatter plot with only
one Legend we can pass the data and use
scatter to make the charts
so basically we're just plotting the
scatter chart in bokeh here
and this is what our minutes scatter
chart looks like now we're plotting this
for one t we're plotting the minute at
which one sabotage was fixed
and another cool thing about bokeh
charts is that you can always zoom into
them or zoom out of them to better see
where your data is plotted
so this is a scattered chart which has
only one variable which is one t and the
minute at which it was plotted to make a
scattered chart with more variables
we are going to need to use Circle
which is a method of figure object which
we've already seen before the circle is
one of the many blotting styles which
are provided by bokeh you can also use
triangles or many more you don't have to
make each point a circle
so we're gonna be plotting
so we're going to be plotting the
sabotage is fixed and the minute at
which they were fixed
and we're gonna be blotting three
different Circles of three different
colors
I mean each of them correspond to how
many sabotages were fixed at what time
zero sabotages at what time one sabotage
at what time and two at what time so
let's run this
so as you can see here
when zero sabotages were fixed these
were the times
when one was fixed this was the time at
which it was fixed and when two was
fixed this is the time that it was fixed
at now the x-axis is our minutes and the
y-axis is the sabotage
when you hover over it you can see
various information about where each
circle is plotted
so this has an index of 10 the data X Y
will tell you the
exact x coordinate and the y coordinate
and the screen XY will tell you the
screen pixels on which it is plotted
so now we've taken a look at pie charts
let's move on to histograms
so what exactly is a histogram
histograms are used to plot numerical
data according to the range that they
fall into the data is plotted in the
form of bins or rectangles and the
y-axis corresponds to the amount of data
present in a certain range or at a
certain point
so this is what a histogram looks like
this is a histogram of the distribution
of minutes
so the x-axis has the range
within which this data Falls like over
here the first range is from 0 to 2.9
and second one is from 2.9 to 5.8 each
range has a value of 2.9 and the
corresponding y-axis or the height of
the bins
tells us how much data is present within
this range
so this is how you can read histograms
now let's see how we can plot them using
python bokeh now let's see the
distribution of minutes in the Among Us
game we will use his to plot a histogram
foreign
the minutes of our game uh we're going
to be using the DF Min column for this
and we're going to be converting it
into
an integer
so this is the column that we're going
to be plotting let's plot this
again we're going to be using the plot
bouquet function here because it makes
plotting data frames very easy the kind
of data frame that we're going to be
using is the histogram or hist
and the title of a
graph is going to be
distribution
of minutes
so let's run this
now this is what a histogram looks like
now this is when we've only plotted one
variable which is minutes
yeah so another thing that you can plot
is a stacked histogram
a stacked histogram is when you plot
various histograms on top of each other
so let's see how this works
for a start histogram we want to see if
the game length has a correlation with
an amount of imposters and crewmates in
our game
so to do this we're going to be creating
a small data frame which has the game
length and the team columns combined
so let's do that
okay
and this is what this looks like
so all you have to do to plot this in
the form of a start histogram is use the
hist function again so so
let's see how that is done
and let's give this figure a size of
see
750 comma 350.
so so let's run this again and this is
the Stacked histogram that you get
we have two different columns which are
plotted on top of each other
uh versus the game length
so basically this tells us that when
game length was between uh 0 to 0.9
minutes the number of imposters was way
higher than the number of crewmates
and the longer the game went on the
number of imposters decreased and the
number of crewmates just kept getting
longer and longer now obviously you can
say that the number of crewmates is
decreasing as the game goes on to but
this is because the imposters would have
killed off most of the crewmates as you
can see here towards the end there are
no imposters which means that most of
the imposters were rejected and the
crewmates won
so now we've taken a look at histograms
let's move on to bar plots and
understand how exactly they're different
from histograms so in histograms you
have plotted numerical data
distributions as of yet in buyer plots
you plot for categorical data it also
uses bins to plot the amount of data
when the bins are stacked on top of each
other it's called a stat bar chart this
is basically what a bar chart looks like
the difference is this does not have its
own range
each bar is used to represent a
categorical data and the height is used
to tell us how much of that categorical
data is present
so now let's see how we can plot a bar
plot so again we're gonna be making a
small data frame of the task completed
and the value counts of how many tasks
have been completed
to plot a Bad plot figure I'm using plot
bokeh again and the kind of plot that we
want to plot is bar
so let's run this and see what we get
so here is your buy plot the task
completed in this case is categorical
data
and the counts basically tells us how
many value counts fall into each
category
so zero task completed are 69
one task completed is 117 two tasks
completed is 10 and so on
uh from this bar chart you can say that
the most number of tasks completed is
seven and the least task completed are
10.
now let's create a stat bar chart and
let's see who wins imposters or
crewmates
to create a start bar chart what we're
going to be doing is that we're going to
be creating a different smaller data
frame of team and outcome
to make sure that the bar chart is
stacked all you have to do is include a
stacked attribute in your bar function
and change its value to true
so let's run this and see and here you
can see that we have a start bar chart
so you can see that crewmates who have a
lot more data have one 981 times and
lost 780 times while imposters have lost
205 times and won 216 times
so the crewmates have won significantly
far more than the number of times
imposters have won
now let's take a look at stacked
vertical bar charts so so far the bar
charts that we've been looking at have
been horizontal which means that the
data goes upwards
for a vertical bar charts we're gonna be
seeing if all tasks have been completed
or not
so uh in the data frame column all tasks
completed we're going to be replacing
the values of yes and no with tasks
completed and tasks not completed
we're also going to be creating
a smaller data frame of the outcome
column and the task completed column
to plot a stacked vertical bar chart you
are going to be using
python book a DOT bar H function and
you're going to be changing the Stacked
attribute to true
this is what is stacked horizontal bar
chart looks like
so where we can see that the missing
values is represented by Blue task
completed by Orange and task not
completed by Green
here you can see the total outcome you
can see how many wins how many tasks are
completed and how many tasks are not yet
completed
and the same goes for losses you can see
how many losses have occurred how many
tasks are completed and how many tasks
were not completed this is a very good
way of representing a lot of data in a
relatively smaller area
now the way we can interpret this graph
is that we can say that finishing the
task will automatically
ensure that the crewmates have won so
there's a higher number of people who
need to complete the task to win the
game
another very unique type of bar chart
that you can have is a bi-directional
bar chart
so let's plot a bi-directional bar chart
in which the bars will be going both
ways to the left and to the right
they're gonna be blotting
a horizontal bar chart over here
to make it easier for you to see
to have a bi-directional bar chart you
need positive values and negative values
the center
is going to be at 0.
so here we are going to be making the
loss features negative by multiplying
the loss feature with the minus 1 value
so here we go the losses are all
negatives and the wins are all positives
right now let's run this
and see how many losses and wins have
occurred for each user
so user one
has 42 losses
and 58 wins but you can easily see
whether they have one more or law or
lost more by comparing the height of the
bars
for the wins and the losses so we can
easily say that in this scenario user
one has one more times than they have
lost
the same can be said for user too where
the
winds bar is significantly higher than
the losses bar
so this is how you can plot and
understand a bi-directional bar chart
so we've taken a look at how we can plot
bar charts and the various types of bar
charts that are available to us in
Python bokeh
now let's take a look at area plots
when the area below a line is shaded
using an area chart we can see how the
values of different groups change over a
period of time
the area chart has different baselines
to show the vertical range of data
here we've
plotted the sabotage is fixed versus the
minutes at which they were fixed at
right so these are the minutes and the
sabotage is fixed are of two types 0 t
and one t
so the number of minutes that we're
considering here is somewhere around 28
ish right and 0 t as you can see has a
way higher value
so one really good thing about area
plots especially in this case is that
they have two ranges and they have
another range on the y-axis which is
which tells us how the number of
sabotage is fixed is ranging
so zero sabotage is fixed you can see
how the value keeps fluctuating and uh
how the value changes for different
minutes
and the same can be said for 1T
now 1T has a baseline which is over here
which is just above the zero T Baseline
this doesn't necessarily mean that this
is where one t starts and this is where
it ends this just means that it ranges
from zero all the way here and we can
compare very easily how zero sabotage is
fixed and one sabotage is fixed range or
change with respect to each other at at
the same time
now the first thing that we're going to
be doing to plot our area chart is that
we're gonna be creating another data
frame this is called DF minutes which is
going to be comprising of the minutes
column of our data frame and the
sabotage is fixed column of the same
data frame
for DF Min we're going to be renaming
The Columns to 0t and 1T
and the only columns that were going to
be considering out of the five different
columns that we have are the zero T and
the 1T column
we're going to be combining all of these
together in a format which can be
plotted
by using bokeh and column data source
helps us do this it helps us convert our
various data frame columns into lists
next we're going to be using the figure
function and we're going to give our
figure a width of 400 a height of 400
and the title of sabotage is fixed
versus the minutes at which they were
fixed at
to plot a stacked area graph you are
going to be using V area underscore
stack function
from the figure module
you're going to be passing in your y
parameters which is y naught and y1
because we have two different y
parameters here and the X parameter
which is DF minutes
the color that you're going to be using
is gray and light gray
the legend labels are the names that
you've already put here which is 0 t and
one t and the source of your data is
going to be this column data source
now let's run this and see how our area
chart looks so this is our area chart
we've gotten two different sabotages
here and two different times at which
they occur which is 0 D and one t
the minutes tells us how many sabotages
were fixed at each time basically how
long it took to fix a sabotage and the
minute during the game at which they
occurred
now let's take a look
add the layout function of our bokeh
library
the layout function will let us build a
grid of plots and widgets we can have as
many rows and columns or grids of plots
in one layout
using the layout function we can see
various graphs at the exact same time
mainly used for Designing dashboards it
lets you build grids of plots
so this is basically what your layout
function will help you do this is going
to look very good in a website because
it's going to arrange up plots in a way
that we can easily see all of them
and understand all of them without any
loss of data
this is also arranged very neatly which
is exactly what the layout functions
allow us to do
so now let's take a look at how the
layout function can be implemented in
Python bokeh
now if the layout functions there are
many different layout options which are
available you have the column function
which allows you to display plots
vertically
and you have the grid function which
lets you display plots in the form of
grids
now for example
um
let's say that we want to make a
dashboard layout in bokeh
we are going to be considering
three different charts
the first one that we're gonna be
considering is a lollipop chart which is
done here
the next one that we're going to be
considering are two pie charts so this
is how you plot a lollipop chart and
I'll show you what exactly a lollipop
chart is in just a minute the first
thing that you need to know is that the
first graph that we're going to be
plotting
is going to be a graph which has the
user ID versus the outcome of the games
plotted on it
so what we're going to be doing here is
that we're going to be creating a single
data frame which has all of the
user IDs present in it along with the
user and the wins that the user has
obtained Now using this we're going to
be plotting it in the form of
a plot in decreasing order where we have
the top 10 users who have one which
basically means that the users who have
won the most number of games out of all
the users in consideration
so figure one segment will basically
help you plot a line which has a width
of 2 and a circle will be at the circle
at the very top of this segment so
lollipop chart is going to be a
horizontal line with a circle at the
very top sorry the next graph that we're
going to be plotting is going to be a
murdered
and not murdered and missing values pie
chart and the last thing that we're
going to be plotting is a donut chart of
the teams
and the values within them
so these are the three different graphs
that we're going to be plotting and
these are just us creating the graphs
and plotting them the main logic is over
here the main logic is that you want to
set a layout in bokeh as to how you want
to see the charts so the layout that we
are going to be looking at is that we're
going to be having a lollipop chart at
the very top and two smaller pie charts
at the bottom right
so we have three figures here
and the first thing that we're going to
be doing is that we're going to be
giving these figures a line color of
none
the axis is not going to be visible and
the axis labels are not present for
these figures this is the main function
that you're going to be looking at this
is your layout using the grade layout
function that you've imported here from
pyth from bokeh dot layouts you're going
to be creating a grid
and how does the grid know where the
figures are so you've divided the grid
into two this is evident because you
have two figures two main figures here
which are separated by a comma so this
tells the the grid that the page is
going to be divided into two the first
figure which is on top is going to be
Figure 1 and the figure at the bottom
are figure 2 and 3. this means that the
bottom half is going to be further split
into
vertically
let's run this and see what our layout
looks like
so here you have it your entire page is
divided into two the first one has one
the figure one which is the lollipop
chart and the bottom half of our page
has two figures which are the two donut
charts the bottom half is divided
exactly into two as you can see here
this is because that is the grid layout
that we wanted
so this is how you can use the layout
function in Python bokeh it is extremely
easy all you have to do is create a
layout by using the grid function or you
can also use the column function the
column function will plot it in the form
of a single column vertically
using the grid function you can plot
figures vertically as shown here so when
you separate them by commas with respect
to each other they will be plot but they
will be plotted vertically and when you
group them together and separate them
with commas internally they will be
plotted horizontally
so now we've taken a look at how we can
use a layout function
now let's see how we can make
interactive graphs with the help of
bokeh
over here we're going to be using bokeh
to design a dashboard which is used to
represent the horsepower in cars
we are also going to make a graphs
interactive and see how maximum
information can be conveyed with the
help of a single graph
so here we have multiple different cars
and along with the cars will also be
going to be given their horsepowers
a little bit of other information about
them and their images
and over here as you can see
we have a very simple vertical bar chart
but let's see how we can make it
interactive and convey all the
information that we have in our single
data set on this one bar graph
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing is importing all of our
important necessary modules we're
obviously going to have the pandas
modules which is going to be imported to
work with the data frame that we've
given apart from this we're also going
to be importing
figures output files show save and
column data source from bokeh dot
plotting we already know that the figure
function is used to plot different types
of graphs which are given output file is
just used to see a file the show is used
to display our graphs and save will help
you save your graph
now the column data source is the core
of most bokeh plots it provides the data
to the glyph of your plot when you pass
sequences like python lists or numpy
arrays to a bokeh render bokeh
automatically creates a column data
source with this data for you so this is
basically what you're going to be using
to pass data onto your bokeh glyphs
apart from this we're also going to be
using a hover tool function and
a trans and from the transform function
we're going to be importing Factor cmap
we're going to be importing a palette
color which is going to be various
shades of blue
and we're gonna be importing
components from the embedded function of
bokeh let's just see how we can use all
of these and the different things that
they do
the first thing that you're going to be
doing is Reading in your car's data
frame and creating a column data source
so that you can easily pass this data
onto your
bokeh glyphs
so let's run and import all of our
various required functionalities and
import the data as well
so this is what your data set looks like
we have eight different values in our
data set which are the names of
different cars their horsepower their
price and hyperlink of an image
this is what our data set looks like we
have only eight columns so using this
data set we're going to be plotting a
horizontal bar graph again we're gonna
be calling our figure function and we're
going to be given y range to our car
list the Y range is basically just going
to have the different values which are
going to be present on the y-axis we've
given the plot a width of 800 and a
height of 600.
the title of the plot is cars with top
horsepower and the x-axis label is
horsepower
the tools that we're using here is pan
box select zoom in zoom out save and
reset so these are tools that you're
going to be getting on the right side of
your plot
now let's render our glyph or render our
graph the graph that we're going to be
using here is the horizontal bar graph
so the y-axis is going to have cars
and the right are basically the height
of the entire bar is going to depend on
the horsepower the left is going to
start from 0 and the height of each bar
is going to be 0.4
the color that we're going to be giving
is going to be a palette of blue so each
different car will have a different
color of blue associated with it and the
color of blue which is associated with
it will depend on the car list
now fill Alpha 0.9 the source is your
Source data that you have over here
which is the column data source of our
data frame
and the legend is going to be car which
basically means that your entire uh
uh plot is going to have the legend of
car
now we're going to be adding The Legend
This Is Us giving the legend its
orientation so the legend is going to be
vertically oriented the location is
going to be on the top right and the
font size of the text car of a legend is
going to be 10
BX or 10 pixels
we're also going to be adding a hover
tool inside this Hardware tool
this hover tool tips will basically tell
you what you're going to be seeing
in the hover toolbox
so we're going to be creating this the
help of an HTML format
the first thing that you're going to be
seeing is the name of the car
the next
column will have the price of the car
the horsepower of the car and the image
now the image is in the form of a
hyperlink and this is going to be Auto
populated in your hover tool the width
of the image is going to be 800.
so we are going to add all of these
hover tools to our P image and we are
finally going to be showing you the
graph and what it looks like
so this is your bouquet plot here the
name the title of the plot is cars with
top horsepower this is your Legend which
is cars
the name of each car is given here along
with the color which is associated with
it here are the different tools that we
have
you can save this
you can reset it you can zoom out you
can zoom in
you can select the boxes and you can pan
your image
so here we're zooming in here we're
zooming out if we save this the plot
automatically gets downloaded in your
system and if you reset it the image
goes back to exactly what it looked like
when it was first opened now here you
have the names of the different cars on
the y-axis and you have the various
horsepowers on the x-axis
let's take a look at our Harvard tool
so here you have the name of the car
which is on top you have the price and
you have the horsepower and as you can
see you have the image which is hyper
pop which is populated instantly from
the hyperlink that was available to us
now the color palette associated with
each car
gets darker the more the horsepower of
the car increases so here we have cars
with top horsepower which are arranged
in an
ascending order from the top and a
descending order from the bottom
so this is another way that you can use
bokeh to create extreme interactive and
informational graphs here in just half a
page and this is us making a huge plot
right we can also decrease the size of
the plot if you want to but basically in
half a page we've conveyed all the
information
ranging from the name of the car to its
model to the horsepower that is ha that
it has its price and also its image
and this is also a very good way to
compare it
so these are just some functionalities
which are provided in bokeh itself no
other
data visualization Library will let you
work so well with graphs and will let
you customize your graphs to this extent
visual database helps you perform
exploratory data analysis and find
hidden patterns in the data it lets you
analyze Trends in the data and draw
meaningful conclusions today we will
learn how to visualize data using
Tableau power bi and Excel and create
interesting charts and graphs reports as
well as dashboards using leading bi
tools so let's dive in and learn data
visualization for data science hello
hello so what is
companies use business intelligence
Technologies to collect analyze and
present data in order to create
actionable information today's
businesses are always seeking insights
about their customers products and
services so businesses are faced with
many questions such as how do I know my
customers are happy what would make my
customers stay and how can I increase
awareness of my products and services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to Target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
Tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and Oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of Tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use Tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers there's also simple
analytics build right into Tableau such
as Trends and forecasting that can help
you understand your data on a deeper
level Tableau has been a leader in the
Gartner magic quadrant for the last six
years and that includes 2018. here we
will take a look at an overview of the
products offered by Tableau so we have
Tableau desktop which is where you do
all of your development this is where
you connect to and build visualizations
and dashboards today we'll be using
tablet public which is a free version of
Tableau desktop but with some
limitations such as having no R
integration and it can only support up
to a million rows of data also any data
published here is made public so you
can't use this for private company
information then there's a new tool
called Tableau prep where you can
prepare your data by seeing it visually
before you connect and build reports
there's also Tableau online which is a
cloud hosted version of Tableau server a
place where you can publish your
dashboards and it enables you to share
your dashboards in a secure way Tableau
server has as an option to be on
premises so let's just do a quick
comparison between building a
visualization in Excel and building one
in Tableau okay so here we have an Excel
file full of data that we will soon
connect to and use for some of our
demonstration purposes and you can see
that we have information about orders if
we wanted to find out the quantity sold
and the sum of sales for each region we
could do that by creating a pivot table
so we'll make it I selected my cells
we'll make it in a new worksheet and
here we have the beginnings of a pivot
chart and we can grab region and pull it
into our columns and then we'll grab
sales and put it into values and then we
also want to look at quantity and put
that into values and it's automatically
summing up sales and quantity but you
can choose if you want it to be some or
not and then we'll take our values and
put it on rows so that we can see sales
and quantity one on top of the other and
that's the basics of a pivot chart now
let's do a similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and Tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns and we get a similar
thing maybe a little nicer formatted and
then we can come and put quantity there
now we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we can put sales on top by
dragging quantity down in that box we
also have this show me dialog box which
allows you to see what visualizations
you could build using what's already on
the screen or the things that you have
selected so right now we could quickly
switch it to bar charts and now we can
see quantity and sales across our region
with bar charts or we could switch it to
Stacked bars and we can see our quantity
across the regions if you close that we
can see our Legend over here and then
our sales across the region
so in Tableau we have a lot of really
quick flexibility to turn just text into
a visualization so in summary we can see
a side by side of what we made using
pivot tables in Excel and what we made
in a similar amount of time in Tableau
let's get started with the Tableau
installation as for requirements you
need Windows 7 or later or you need your
Mac operating system to be 10.11 or
later here are some of the browsers you
can use to install Tableau we will be
installing Tableau public today and to
do that you just Google Tableau public
download and click on that first link
and then you put in your email address
and click download the app so let's just
look up Tableau public download
and it's this first one you can click
download now it takes you to the Tableau
public page where you can click sign in
and create an account free this gives
you a place to save the visualizations
you make but keep in mind anything you
save on Tableau public is public and
then you come here and you enter your
email address and click download the app
and it should give you executable file
that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open Tableau public so let's go
take a look at the Tableau public
opening page
so this is what Tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to this is more limited in
Tableau public than it is in Tableau
desktop so if you invest in Tableau
desktop you have many many things you
can connect to you can also connect to
data by clicking this drop down connect
data piece that's especially useful when
you've already started your
visualization then we have the central
portion called open this is where
anything that you have opened up
previously will show up you can also
click open from Tableau public and when
you have my connections timed out so I
need to log in
um but when you log in it says no
workbook found try publishing first this
is where you'll see all of your
published Tableau public dashboards over
here we have discover and it has some
how-to videos
visualization of the day which is where
people who have made Tableau public
visualizations get recognized for their
skill and you get something pretty cool
ideas when you look there so let's get
started by connecting to a data source
we'll click Microsoft Excel and we'll
choose our Excel file and open it up and
this is our data source page this shows
you the sheets on the Excel file and
allows you to drag them in so that you
can see the data show up this gives you
a preview of what your data will look
like
you can see the Tableau is starting to
classify our Fields so anything that has
ABC on it shows that that's a column
that has strings in it we also have a
globe which is where Tableau has
recognized these values to be
geographical
so we have
um State and it's recognized that it
contains States it bases it on the
keywords that it stores to identify if
it's geographical and so it takes a look
and you've named it City and it knows
that city is geographical we also have
the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row ID that shows up with the
hashtag and it recognize that's the
number so now that we have our data
source pulled in we can come here and
hit sheet which is where you start to
build your visualization let's take a
look at all the different pieces of this
before we go any further we have the
data that we're connected to up here
it's our orders sheet from the sample
Superstore Excel sheet we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the rose
shelf where you can drag things in to
make changes happen in the visualization
Center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here a neat thing about show me is that
when you hover it'll tell you what types
of fields you need to build it so for a
symbol map try one geographical field
zero or more Dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map and when you're
done with show me you just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet 1 and Sheet two a sheet is
basically just one visualization at a
time
to get rid of the extra sheet we have a
dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have what's called a story
which allows you to show a sequence of
visualizations so that you can tell a
story
perfect okay so we saw that Tableau is
categorizing our different fields and it
is also giving it a role so we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
Dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use Dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view Tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's some by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see it's four distinct values as a
dimension and then we'll double click on
quantity and we can see the numbers here
the measures and you can see here that
it is the sum of quantity and now we can
also double click on sales and we can
see quantity and sales to discuss a
little bit more about dimensions and
measures you can see that in general
measures are numbers and dimensions are
not but sometimes like row ID it is a
number now why would we have a number up
here instead of in the measures so you
can tell the difference between number
whether it should be in measures or it
should be in Dimensions based on whether
you'll need to do any calculations on it
or if you would want to be able to
aggregate it at some time so for sales
if you have
several orders in a day you might want
to know what the sum of those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day and they are on rows two three four
and five you might not want to know the
sum of the rows so Tableau is smart
enough that when it sees ID it knows
that it belongs up in the dimensions now
you can switch so if row ID was actually
something you would want to aggregate
for some reason you can drag it down to
the measures and add it down there
but in our case row ID isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's Dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green it's a little
bit different than what you might expect
and then we'll do sales so now we can
see over the different quantities what
our sales was yeah has been for this
last this period of time that we're
looking at I believe it's four years so
for when people bought three items the
total sales was that number and you can
see that this is an axis so it's from 1
to 15. now if we change it from
continuous to discrete you can see that
one is a label two is a label and it's
not an axis ranging from one to it
doesn't even have 15 because there are
no values under 15. these are just
individual labels so we go back it's
green again and you can see that it's an
axis so we have two greens on here so we
have two axes and change it back to
discrete and now we have one axes and
one set of individual labels so let's go
back to our sheet three we have all of
these different sales by the different
quantity numbers and up here we have our
sorting when you hover it tells you what
kind of sorting is going to happen so we
can sort quantity descending by sales so
we can see that when they buy three
things we add the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right-clicking sort so we
could just sort
by descending or ascending or by sales
or
alphabetic which is not what we want you
can choose the field or you can manually
change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how Tableau Works let's go into a
little more detail Tableau is very much
built on the premise of drag and drop
so let's build a simple visualization
and talk about what each of these shells
and marks cards specifically do so we're
going to make a simple chart which is
average sales by region so we know we
want sales
on
let's do sales on rows now for rows and
for metrics since this is continuous
like we talked about before it's making
an axis
for our sales
um we also can drag region onto columns
and it makes one column per region so
that's how it works with Dimensions if
you
um pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying I want one blank per column I
want one region per column so if you
wanted to do it by instead of region if
you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or control Z Tableau
has the benefit of having unlimited
undos so let's say we wanted to bring on
City let's say we want one column per
City and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
City back off I want one column per
region and for sales
I want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great now
let's say we want to adjust the color of
These Bars you can click on color and
you can select any of them so let's pick
this nice blue or we can pick an orange
and that's how you can determine the
color but if you want something else to
determine the color you can take region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale so if I want them to be
a different color based on sales and I
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous from light to dark but
for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great
um let's say we want to sort this
biggest smallest and we can look at size
here so if we want to adjust the size
manually we can click on it and drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on sales we will drag sales onto
size and we can see that it gets bigger
with bigger sales you do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures for label let's say we
want the sales onto label now we can see
the exact sales number for each region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales for the
west region you can adjust which one
goes on top
see how we have two T's here those are
both labels great uh two of tip let me
click on tool tip it'll show us what's
going to happen when we hover so as I
hover here on East it says region East
sales and that shows the sales amount
now we talked about
I'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average
so we will right click on our sum of
sales here in the rows hover over
measure um which right now is sum and
change it to average and we have a
different result here so let's sort
again and we can see that the South
Region actually has the highest average
of sales which was not the case for the
sum now let's say we want our sum I mean
our sales to be on the label but look
it's giving us the sum of sales label so
we just do the same thing
and change it to average now we can see
our average on the label
the label has some interesting options
like you can format this and we could
say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue and that happens
right there you can also choose to only
show the minimum and the maximum this
becomes handy on a line chart where you
don't want all marks labeled because it
gets very messy but you want the tallest
and the shortest part to be labeled and
maybe you just want the tallest so we'll
click label minimum value and remove
that checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so we could allow
people to look at this but only certain
regions so what we can do is we can come
over to region and right click on it and
click show filter and it will add it to
that filters card and now we can remove
Central from the mix and just look at
those ones you see if we remove South
the new highest East now has the label
but if we put it back in South we'll
have the label again if we don't want to
have these filters we can pull it off
there or if we wanted to filter out
by country oh we just have United States
so let's not filter by country
um but we could pull in category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the South still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that I can mention
here is that you can change the type of
Mark manually so you saw when we pulled
on region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there you
can change it to be a lot of different
type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay now let's look at building a
scatter plot so scatter plot is when you
have a bunch of shapes and points on a
visualization with two axes that are
both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount and if we wanted to see this
per order we'll take order ID and put it
onto detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order ID and putting onto
detail gives us all of these little
points so for each order what was our
sales and what was our discount so we
have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly let's actually do product
ID instead so I'll put it right over top
of order ID and it will replace it
now we see all of our products anything
that has high sales is up here anything
that has high discount is over here you
can see that it sort of has a trend
where things with high sales do not have
high discounts which makes sense if we
wanted to know what category these
products I'll show up in we could take
category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories Tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show just the dimension
that you want to see but it leaves the
other ones in place so for example if we
click on furniture
first we have to turn on the Highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization I
know how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology we can see their
pattern which is a little bit different
so we have them by shape with category
let's drag category onto color as well
if you remember category will determine
the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items they're all over here and most of
the things that are getting high
discounts are office supplies which is
interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product ID
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product ID with
product name
and we see that that is a Canon Image
class Advanced copier so this copier is
our big sales person and office supplies
binders do not give us very many sales
and we're highly discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so let's say we wanted to know by
subcategory what our profit is like we
could grab subcategory and pull it onto
columns and we would say we want one
column per subcategory
and then let's grab profit and pull it
onto rows and you can quickly see which
categories are profitable and which ones
are not so we can also take profit and
put it on the color
so that you can see that even more
clearly right now it is going from
Orange to Blue which is Tableau default
if we wanted to change from what color
to what color it was going we have a lot
of options in here when you go to edit
colors
so maybe you wanted to go from red to
blue
just to emphasize that the profit that's
negative is bad so we can hit apply and
now we can see red to blue we have our
categories here our subcategories here
but let's separate it out by category so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
subcategory off
I'm gonna put on category and that's my
category and then I'm going to put
subcategory on after it so when we put
it in order like this the order matters
in Tableau so first it breaks it up by
category and then inside of that it
breaks it up by subcategory
so Furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under Furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking it up by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture
spread out across star visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category and we can click sort
subcategory descending by profit and now
what it does is within the highest group
within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so what we have here is a quick view by
category by subcategory how we're doing
on profit we can see that tables is our
biggest drain on profit and so if we
wanted to improve the profitability of
furniture maybe we would not sell tables
anymore it's just not working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it is you
can see that there's some of these words
are getting cut off so we can right
click on this axis and click rotate
label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to profit by
sub category then it names the title up
here so it's making it look a little bit
better and then here we have profit and
it shows it but without any like dollar
signs so let's come up here to profit
and click format and you can see that we
can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and we can do it currency by the
thousands and we can get rid of these
decimal places and now you can see it's
just a little bit nicer a little bit
more clear maybe we don't have to have
the label here that says category slash
subcategory so we can hide field labels
for columns
because it's pretty clear that these are
categories and these are subcategories
so those are some formatting tips for
you formatting in Tableau is one of
those things where there are just a lot
of different ways you could change
things
so in more in-depth videos especially
from Simply learn you'll learn more and
more about this
also as we are building these
visualizations if you want to have
access to this data set so that you can
build along with me just make a comment
in the comments below and it's a simply
learned team will send you this data set
now we're going to take a look at
creating a hierarchy in tableau
so I'll make a new tab and we're going
to make a sheet called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at sales as a
number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this and I click add all
members and now we can see all of our
products and their sales overall time so
if we sort this we can see our highest
selling item which we discovered earlier
as the advanced copier and we scroll
down to the bottom our lowest selling
items
so we have our products and we can group
that by subcategory and you can see I
need to put it in the front again
and by category
all right I'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so a product rolls up into a
subcategory which rolls up into a
category you can create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it on the category and it's
going to create a hierarchy we'll call
it our product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory let's do the same
thing by grabbing the product name and
putting it underneath subcategory so now
in those categories the parent then
their subcategory and then there's
product name this allows you to instead
of pulling this off or putting it back
on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales by category by
subcategory by product name this is
really useful when you're creating a
details section for your users and so
when somebody wants to know let's say
you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
chill filter for subcategory and they're
looking at category here and they're
just like I see technology has the
highest sales and I just want to see
technology so I'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so I
just have technology well I want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it oh phones
phones does so I just actually want to
look at phones so I'm going to remove
accessories copiers and machines and
what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now I can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first I'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of Tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly so what we can do is take sales
and drag it onto color let's change our
marks to a square and now it's going to
color each of these it colors every one
of these cells based on its Darkness for
sales this is a little bit heavy of a
color you can click color here and
change the opacity to give it a little
bit of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the West seems to have the highest
sails and that technology in the East is
the very highest so now when we drill
into subcategory it keeps that coloring
and we can see more in depth and quicker
that phones has the highest across most
of them it's not quite the highest in
the west because chairs is the highest
in the west there's one place in Tableau
where hierarchies are built in and
that's in dates so dates in Tableau can
be very complex because they allow very
complex visualizations so we will not go
into depth about dates at this time but
let's take a look at how they work for
hierarchies so we have order date that
we can pull onto columns here and you
can see that it's blue meaning that it's
discrete so each one of these is a
header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag profit onto rows so now
we can see our profit over time for each
of these years
and Tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when I click this
Plus on columns it'll split it out into
quarters so this is a header and these
are all subheaders underneath that
header because it is distinct
um and discrete right now instead of
continuous so it's split out year year
year and quarters quarters quarters
quarters this allows you to quickly
compare quarter one across all the years
and Quarter Two across all the years and
quarter four across all the years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out to color and
now we have one line for each category
and we can see that a drop in technology
is a big part of the responsibility for
that drop we were seeing in quarter two
of 2016. so let's take that back off and
let's take quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when I change
it to a bottom one year same thing same
year it changes it to be green and now
it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when I
press the plus and it changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going and drill down to
month
you can go pretty far now when we add
category as color we get our three lines
for the three categories and we also
have highlighting turned on here still
so when we click on technology we can
highlight technology with the others in
the background so we don't lose the
context of the other categories
let's take that back off next let us
talk about calculated Fields so we'll
make a new sheet and we're going to
create our first calculated field we can
create a calculated field by clicking
this Arrow which gives us some options
and clicking create calculated field or
we can come and click in the white space
below Dimensions or below measures and
we right click and click create
calculated field let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start Auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or values you can use or
you can come and drag it in so if we
want profit and we want sales if we do
profit divided by sales that is a profit
ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate and that will duplicate our
field but I just want to start over
again so I'll click create calculated
field and I will call it profit
ratio aggregated
and then this one we're gonna do some
click of profit
click divided by sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio aggregated and
profit ratio unaggregated how will those
behave differently in Tableau let's look
at this by looking at a single order so
first let's bring on all the orders and
all the products under that order and
let's look at this order so I want to
filter this whole dashboard to only this
order so I can right click on it and
click keep only that creates a filter up
here
that only has that box checked and if I
want to get rid of this later I can just
pull it right off of filters and
everything will come back but I want it
so keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated I double clicked on it
and I added it here and profit ratio
unaggregated again double clicking
another side by side let's give us a
little bit of more room
so when I dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side in the entire titles okay so I
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that Tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and I brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now so when we're looking at it without
any aggregation these two calculations
are the same profit ratio aggregated
let's look at that again we'll click
edit and that's the one where we sum
profit and some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that I use when I'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what I expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at 0.5 or 50 and
that's because profit is eight in sales
is 16. for Adam's telephone messaging
now let's take off project name when we
take off product name we can see that
they start to vary they've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller so if we
take profit at
219.1 and divide it by sales at
508.6 we get 0.4 not 1.8 so where does
this 1.8 come from well let's put a
product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however does the
calculation profit divided by sales and
then sums it afterwards you can see it
right here it's the sum of profit ratio
on aggregated so it makes this
calculation and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5 and that's where we get our 1.8
which is what we see when we pull off
product name 1.8 so for most
calculations you want to do profit ratio
aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation so let's
remove profit ratio on aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board Tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on Windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start you over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on really made
a mess when you're trying things out
okay so we're going to build a
visualization and we're going to look at
Region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region now
let's say we also wanted to see each
region by sales per customer so let's
create some calculated fields that will
help us do that let's create our first
calculated field that's going to get us
a count of customers
let's call it total number of customers
and so we have customer name and
customer ID let's do count distinct of
customer ID and that gives us the total
number of customers
apply so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
custom
perfect but that's just one part of our
calculation we want to see total sales
divided by total number of customers so
let's make our second calculated field
and we're going to call it sales per
customer
we're going to do our sum of sales which
we can drag in and divide that by total
number of customers now you see that
calculated field we just made pops up
inside of our calculation dialog box and
we hit apply and it shows up so we hit
OK and let's replace total number of
customers with sales per customer and
now we can see our sales per customer
ratio and which ones have the highest or
for this next part I'm going to make a
couple of visualizations in a row that
I'll apply to the same information using
a couple of different tactics so first
let's use show me so I want to look at
Region and sales for this visualization
so I'm going to control click region
after I clicked sales so one more time
I'm going to click on sales and I'm
going to control click region and I'm
going to click show me and it's going to
give me all of the different
visualizations I could make with region
and sales let's pick
tree map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales by region and we have
the size and the color of the box is
both sales so let's say we wanted the
size to be sales but the color to be
profit so let's grab profit and drag
that on to sales so now we can see our
most profitable to our least profitable
let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to Advanced and
make the center number
zero this means that it will never be
red unless it's less than zero so let's
hit apply so it's all blue and if
anything ever goes negative then it will
be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales profit by region
perfect now we're going to start using
our geographical Fields so we have state
city country and postal code let's
double click on State and see what
happens
awesome so it is generated these two
Fields Tableau has generated longitude
and latitude for us and it's been able
to recognize the states in the United
States and where they're located and
given it a longitude and latitude so
next we will look at sales by state by
double clicking on sales and what it's
done was change the size of the dot
based on sales now I think I'm going to
move sales from size to color and it has
automatically changed it to a filled map
instead of dots on a map perfect so now
we can see the states
with the biggest amount of sales let's
put it back onto size and we have our
circles again
let's put sales on the size not stayed
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the Tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap but it's up to you as the
Builder okay so we have size for sales
again and for profit onto color again so
you can see anything that is more
profitable is darker and anything that
is less profitable or less than zero in
this case is Orange Let's do what we did
with color before
change it to red blue diverging and set
our Center Point to zero okay
so now we know that if anything is red
it was negative in profit perfect let's
name this sheet
sales profit by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so this is when we
drag something to the columns shelf just
remember we want one column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what I want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have one bar with
the axis of sales for furniture office
supplies and Technology
now let's take profit and also put it on
rows so now we have two bar charts one
for sales and one for profit we can
change which one is a bar and which one
is maybe a bubble chart by clicking on
its appropriate marks card so if we want
to change them both we can click on all
and change them both to maybe circles
and you can see how they go up and down
but if we want to just change one of
them let's put those back to automatic
we'll go to profit and change that one
to the circles so now we can see those
profit numbers and if we want them to be
overlaid on the same area we would right
click on profit the second measure on
the rows and click dual axis so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space one of them is a bar chart
and one of them is a bubble chart and we
can see our sales versus our profit at
least they're not the same amount of
dollars obviously but we can see a
higher sales and a higher profit we also
have medium sales and a medium profit we
have a medium sales but a really low
profit and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet as
sales
profit
by category
and finally we're going to make our
details sheet so we're going to go down
to subcategory level and bring it onto
rows and remember subcategory can expand
out to the actual products let's bring
that back in and we're going to bring
sales onto columns which makes this a
sales bar chart and profit onto columns
which makes this a profit bar chart now
let's color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color now sales is colored by sales
we'll do the same thing here we did
before we'll go red blue diverging
and make the center zero we actually
don't have to do that for sales because
sales will never be negative but it's
pretty important for profit so we'll go
to the profit marks card and take profit
onto color
and do the same thing there we have red
blue diverging
Advanced Center is zero great so now if
it's negative it will be there so let's
sort this by profit and so both of them
have sorted with profit in mind and we
can easily see our subcategories that
have a negative profit let's rename this
and we'll call it our details sheet so
now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do with similar
information
I think I want these bigger on the
states so I'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have information over here that shows
you what sheets you can bring on these
get a little bit more complex so they'll
be covered in more in-depth type of
videos and then we have our size so we
could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size and we're going to make it 1400 by
a thousand and this is our dashboard
size so let's bring on sales profit by
region sales and profit by state now a
map needs a little bit more horizontal
space than region does let's bring sales
and profit by category underneath the
region and the D detail underneath the
state give our map more space again
perfect now Tableau has this neat
feature called uses filter so you can
click use this filter here and now if I
click on any of these it will filter the
other dashboards based on these features
so if I just want to look at the South
and I click on South it zooms in to all
my South States now my categories have
updated to be just the South ones and my
details have updated as well so we could
see that Central has pretty big sales
you know bigger than the South but the
profit is lower than the South so we can
click on Central and focus on Central
let's use that uses filter on all three
of these dashboards that lead us up to
the detail so building a quick dashboard
like this let's make this taller would
allow you to do some sort of analysis
such as let's take a look at Central
because they have relatively High
profits but low sales so we click on
Central and then we see oh man Texas is
having a really hard time so let's click
on Texas and now we're seeing in Texas
that we have negative profit in these
categories so we can control click on
furniture and office supplies and we can
see all of our products that are really
just killing us in Texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for Texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you back out of that
subcategory section you can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
Click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet and
let's make a quick visualization that
will apply our parameters and our sets
to
so let's take a look at all of our
customers by their sales and let's sort
customer name descending by sales great
so now we're going to make a parameter
that will allow the user of the
dashboard to choose how many customers
they want to see how many of our top
customers that they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make an integer and
we're going to give them the option to
choose the number of customers within a
range our low is going to be 5 so we'll
let them see five
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of five let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10. okay so now if you want to see how
this parameter looks you can come down
to parameters before we only had
dimensions and measures on the left side
of our Tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that it's appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
the parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allowed them to go down to five
and up to 20 with steps of five great
now we're going to create a set a set is
a custom field that defines a subset of
data based on some conditions so the set
we're going to build is going to be
based on customer name so when you right
click on customer name you can come down
and click create hover on Create and
create a set with so far when we created
a parameter and a calculated field you
clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on Create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
Define by the parameter
Buy sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10. we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose another field
here for it to be defined by and it's
sales and we want it to be by sum of
sales if we wanted it to be by the
average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers by average profit but we want
sales and some Okay so we've created our
set and we can drag it onto rows to see
how it works and we can see these are
our top 10 customers by their sales and
we have this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15.
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10 and let's grab the
set and drag it onto our filters so now
we have filtered the data down to our
top ten if this were applied to a
dashboard this would allow the end user
to see the top 10 quickly and then maybe
expand it out to the top 20 if they're
interested in that information now let's
move on to creating a donut chart so a
donut chart is basically a pie chart
with a white center so let's start by
building a pie chart which in Tableau is
pretty easy especially if you use show
me so let's create a pie chart for each
category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're gonna control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click pi and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one Pi for each region we can take
region and drag that onto columns so we
have one column for each region and then
one Pi for each of them you can see that
the pi varies in size based on sales as
well as the angle is for sales so East
has more sales in general than South
and this helps you to see that
technology has smaller sales in the
South than it does in the East so I
recommend keeping if you're going to
make pie charts allowing the size of the
pie chart to be affected as well as the
angle by whatever measure you're using
but for our purposes for donut charts
we're going to want them to all be the
same size so we took sales off of size
and now we have all of our pie charts
the same size now we're going to make
what's called a dual axis chart and to
make a dual axis chart we have to have
two axes so let's grab number of records
and we'll grab it and drag it to rows
and we will change it from sum to
minimum and that's because every record
will have a minimum number of rows of
one and then they all end up on the same
axis great and now we're going to make a
second number of Records by minimum and
we can do that by doing those steps
Again by by dragging number of Records
up here and changing it to minimum again
or a quick trick that I can show you is
if you want to duplicate anything you
have on the chart here you can just hit
control and then click and drag it and
it will duplicate it so if you wanted
your number of Records to also be down
here onto your details or on your labels
you can control click it and then leave
it there great so now we have our two
axes and we have our two marks cards
that each affect their own set of
visualizations so let's go to this top
one affects these so let's show that by
changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these then we'll do
that by changing it to Circle so now
each of these are a circle let's take
category off of color and we can take
some of sales off of detail and let's
change the color to white and now we're
going to put this white circle on top of
our pie chart by clicking here on our
second measure and clicking dual axis
and now it's got them lined up one on
top of the other and we have our donut
chart so if we want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our Inner Circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one donut chart for each
region and if we wanted to take this
header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here you can come
and edit that by clicking on label and
changing its alignment so let's put it
in the middle
perfect so now we can see our header
here so we don't need it down here
anymore you can right click and click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies so to get how the number of
sales here for each of them let's go to
remember our PI marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie can tell
you how much sales they have if you take
the sales here that's on label right
click and click format we can change
that to currency and let's get rid of
our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with Central so we
go back to affecting our Circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four donut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers for each segment and also
for the donut as a whole you can also
change the colors the Tableau selects
for each slice by coming to the marks
card that has color for the pie so
category color and clicking edit colors
and you could change it to any of these
automatic ones or if you double click on
one it gives you all of the options for
colors that you could possibly want
there's also several different palettes
you could choose from so let's say we
like this one and you can just click
assign palette and it will grab those
off of there those look very similar to
what we have already so I'm going to
pick a different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes you can fit your business a
little bit more specifically perfect
let's say we make our pies bigger
increase that size and we'll also
increase the center size oh not that
much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show two pie charts at
the same time or a pie chart that's kind
of split up by different categories this
has been available in some other tools
and Tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our generic category
by sales so with control click sales we
come over to show me and click pi and it
makes our pie for us it remembers the
colors that you have determined in other
pages so that's a nice feature again
let's make it entire view so we can see
our pie nice and big and now we're going
to create our dual axis again so we grab
number of Records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of Records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes let's come to our
top one and make it bigger that affected
both of them because we still have sales
on size
for both of them so sales is affecting
the size of the pie chart as well as the
size of the angles so let's take sales
off of size for both of them and make
the second pie chart a little smaller
perfect now let's also affect our second
pie chart by having the color defined by
region instead of defined by sales let's
talk about how I'm replacing it with
region so you could change the color by
dragging region onto color and that
replaces it or let's go back and we can
drag region right on top of the thing
we're trying to replace and it will
replace it there
great so now we have the smaller Circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the categories on the top one with
being able to find by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to I'm just going to keep following
that's right down apply great and then
we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
to allow you to see the inner Pi
separate from the outer pie Maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look and we can make them both
bigger like we did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
we'll take sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
change that zero line To None perfect
get rid of some of the Clutter on this
visualization I still feel like this
outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have Min number of Records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come to Tool tip right
as you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tooltip and
we're just going to erase mid number of
Records I erased too much you need to
leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
Min number of Records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when Tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen these visualizations are a little
bit more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so I recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below in
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have at this point in the
presentation we're going to put together
some dashboards so first let's build our
worksheets for this dashboard we're
going to build a worksheet called sales
by year which adds the name up here and
we're going to take our our order date
and drag it onto columns and now we want
this to be a continuous axis so we're
going to change it to our continuous
year and now we have an axis and we're
going to look at sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto labels and if we want to
have different color lines for each
region for example we can drag region
onto color
and that splits our lines up into the
different regions and gives us a legend
over here perfect now we're going to
duplicate this sheet by right clicking
down here and clicking duplicate now we
have sales by year two let's rename it
to
profit by year and then let's drag
profit right over top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
of these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
sum of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our access
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
let's do a couple of things to clean
these up like right click here go format
and we'll change our numbers to currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars one thing
you can do in Tableau is let's undo that
since sales is going to be dollars
pretty much everywhere we use it we can
Define our default property for these
numbers so when we right click on the
measure here you can go to default
properties and you have the options to
change the defaults for any of these
things and we're going to change our
number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit okay and that also
has updated this sheet now that it only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still Define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet let's do the
same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this our overall
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine I think it fits nicely on the
laptops that I use and that is used by
most of our customers and let's drag
sales by year now watch what happens
when I drag it on here it brings sales
by year but it also brings the legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same Legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second Legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts let me click on Central and
you see it highlights Central in both
charts that's great so now we have a
dashboard showing us profit by year and
sales by year but let's say we want to
be able to filter this dashboard to just
maybe one category so let's go back to
our sales by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit OK and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here and we're going to do a
similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here so now
we have a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
I don't feel when we go to overall
we can come to our drop down here more
options
hover over filters and you can see
category now here's an interesting thing
that we'll see even though we have a
category filter on both charts when I
take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be that's because we have
two different filters for category one
on the sales worksheet and one on the
profit by year worksheet I'll show that
by clicking here going to filters and
web category now we have category that
will affect profit by year and not sales
by year that's not what we want we want
one filter to affect them both so let's
back it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year and we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to the profit
by year sheet you can see that it now
has category on there let's go to
overall let's come here filters category
and now we have a filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do a couple more filters so we can
do by category let them filter out
regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is apply to
worksheets selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them change their time
selection so this one's a little bit
different since we've already determined
that we wanted year and we wanted it to
be continuous filters for continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for these discrete fields and
that's because continuous fields are a
range instead of just a list so we don't
list out a continuous field we make a
range for it so we've already defined
that we want it to be continuous year
and if I come over here and click on
right click order date and click show
filter it's doing discrete year by
default
so remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at let's come up here to year
that's already marked as continuous and
click show filter and now it is year but
it's based on a range and we have this
slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization let me show you a
trick to make this apply to both not a
trick but just if you have not applied
it to both worksheets but you already
added it to the visualization see it's
here but it's only affecting one
worksheet you can change the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to the worksheet where the
filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by each of the
regions we can do that as well so let's
go back to our sales sheet as a quick
tip you can go to the sheet by clicking
this go to sheet button here or here in
the event that you want to go to a sheet
but you don't want to scroll back and
forth to find where it is so go to sheet
now we're going to do a dual access
chart again like we showed earlier and
I'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by if I change the
opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the row section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top I can see this
versus this this now if we wanted to un
hover show that this is overall sales we
can click on tool tip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put oh we don't want it to be Orange
Let's Make It Black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it
um a little bit more of a color that'll
stand out just a little darker than the
others perhaps
so when we go back to our work our
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for our profit by year go to sheet
and
control
drag release
we'll go to our marks card for this
second sheet and pull off region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not Orange
overall profit
okay and right click
dual axis there we go now I forgot to do
one thing on the last dashboard when you
make a dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily
um sync up these axes and so this axis
over here is for the overall line and
this axis over here is for the region
line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should edit our axes and instead of
calling it just profit over here
we will change it to overall profit
and over here
profit by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one or you can come here
and click synchronize access so it's
very clear that this is much bigger than
these and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him okay
synchronize the axis then we don't need
both of these headers so we can come
here and click show header and we just
have the one let's do the same thing on
sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind when we
do filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
have we filter to two
then it's only the sum of those two so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered
um why does this happen why doesn't this
line always show the total no matter
what you select here well that's because
this filter applies to the whole
dashboard so it filters this line to
those regions just as much as it filters
these lines
foreign
so I'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so let's do it using show me we'll
click on region
and then we will control click on sales
open up show me click Pi let's close it
again great so now we have the sales bar
region Pi we'll make it the entire View
and when you hover you can see that it's
showing us sales in dollar amounts now
it would be more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of Pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole at
100 so let's come here to our slice size
we'll right click on it and we're going
to use what's called a quick table
calculation and change it to percent of
total so now when you hover you can see
that the West is 31 of the pi
great let's also label each of these
slices so I'm going to control click and
drag region onto label and add region to
the labels I'm going to undo that and
show you what would happen if I just
dragged region onto labels without
copying it without holding Ctrl it will
move it and get rid of our colors and we
don't want that so we're going to
control and drag another way to do this
let's go back is by taking region and
dragging it onto label just straight
from over here but in this case for the
sum of sales where we've applied the
quick table calculation we want that
quick table calculation to also show up
in our label so I'm going to control and
drag and it brings that quick table
calculation along with it if I were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and I'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead control move and
drag that's probably one of my very
favorite table of Turks great now let's
add a filter for region so I'm going to
right click here and click show filter
and we will make sure that this gets
added to all of our sheets once we've
made them all okay next sheet we're
going to call this sheet sales by state
let's do a map great so one way to get
your map started is to double click on
any of these Dimensions that have a
globe next to them so with this we want
to go with State we can double click on
State and it starts mapping out state so
what it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here and another way to
get going so let's go back is to click
on the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our Maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
going to do a filth map
click on that so now we have our filled
map based on State
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label and you can see we
have the dollar sign and the money
formatting that we made earlier and
let's control and drag State onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here on the ellipses and edit it there
so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there I think I lost my
Center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think great okay
so now you can see that it puts the
state on top you can also see in some of
these places where they're super close
together that you can't see all of the
state's labels and that's because
um this option here in labels is
unchecked allow labels to overlap other
marks so Tableau senses when the marks
are too close together and it's going to
become too hard to read and we'll hide
anything that overlaps with each other
if we click this option now you see
everything but it gets a little crowded
over here so let's unselect that and
you'll be able to see what the sales are
upon hover
great now we have our sales by state for
filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your Dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters
um so now we could add the lowest amount
for a state is nine hundred and twenty
dollars for sales for this time period
and we could filter out ones that have
sales lower than that but I think this
isn't what I want let's remove that
filter let's do it for the state show
filter great so now we could filter out
a state we could just show Arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization new sheet rename it to be
called sales buy Sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategories of our
hierarchy press plus now we have sub
category and category and let's bring on
sales it's defaulting to this bar chart
which is perfect that's what I want and
now we could color it by subcategory and
this is a discrete coloring we could
also color it by sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to add to the distinction
between the different categories so
that's very clear where they start and
stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for a subcategory so let's
bring on category as our filter so we'll
right click here click show filter
there's category and let's do a filter
for our date so we're going to come here
to order date let's drag it onto filters
and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit OK right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard our sales
dashboard and change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us but this time you can see
it added both the Legends and the filter
so last time we created the filters
after we built the dashboard but this
time you can see that the filter
um gets brought in when we brought in
the dashboard let's do our sales by
State Side by Side here and let's do
sales by subcategory underneath so I
dragged it you can see how I pull it
towards the bottom of the dashboard and
it kind of fills in the space where it's
going to be and then brings it in so now
it's brought in all our filters and all
of our Legends it defaults to putting
the filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
gonna make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in Tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and um a lot of resizing to get things
the way you want them to be give our map
more room
and we have a mixture over here of
Legends and filters let's move our
Legends out of there so we can grab this
Legend and come and put it on this side
and this Legend come put it over here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this Legend goes up here with this one
I'm going to actually click here and
change it from a tiled so right here it
says tiled object to a floating object
that lets it sit on top of a
visualization I'm going to put it on top
of this visualization right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one Circle there's no
size comparison so it's not like we have
several circles and we have to look and
see which one's the biggest so that we
can tell that the amount of sales so we
don't need this Legend and we can just
remove it from the dashboard let's clean
up some of these we have several
different versions of what your filters
could look like so my personal favorite
is multiple values drop down it gives
you some of the most flexibility but if
you wanted them to only be able to
select a single value you could turn it
into a radio button list so that it's
the selected all or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the Range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
Technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so let's do multiple value drop
downs for big ones like State there is
the option of searching so I know I want
Utah and I search and there's Utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for byproducts and that
would allow somebody to look at just one
product at a time if they know their
name of the product but also not have to
just open up the product list and scroll
and scroll and scroll since there are
very a lot of products so we can filter
by region by doing this oh this is a
great reminder you saw that this did not
change all the visualizations we have
yet to apply these filters to all the
worksheets so let's do that right now
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
and we will click all on dashboard hit
okay
we'll do this again
until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe
um a total number up here at the top
that you just wanted to stay the same
all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters oh great great
so we can change what region we're
looking at by selecting Central here and
then we're just looking at Central
throughout all the visualizations I love
looking at it on a map and seeing just
one at a time it just really makes the
region name just stand out to you but if
we wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on Central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that Texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
Central the scale updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and Texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when I filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at Texas we click this this updates to
just Central this updates to just Texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say let me scroll down a
bit storage now everything updates to
the storage it's interesting I wouldn't
have known very quickly that there are
some states that didn't have any storage
sales but now when we click on storage
we can tell I showed you before that you
can control click and look at binders
and storage and it puts those two
together also in Tableau you can drag
now we could select all of these so we
have our binders envelopes Fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
I don't know what's up with Wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and let's get started on our
next one our next dashboard is going to
be the profit version of this dashboard
so some of these visualizations we can
use again so let's go to sales by region
right click and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse a visualization because like
I mentioned before you got to make sure
everywhere that sales is used you have
to replace it with profit I'm also going
to drag this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall than the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
Circle and onto the text now when I
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total Again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay Dr profit by
region great we're clear of filters and
let's add back in a region filter and
this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what I want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier Tableau will
not allow you to make a worksheet that
has the same name as another worksheet
you can call it number one or since it
does put the title up here you can put
an extra space at the end or it does
detect that space it counts it as a
different title even though it's the
same title just with a space that does
cause some issues so like when we're
looking here and we're saying oh profit
by subcategory I want that oh this is
when we made it but you don't want this
one you want this one and it gets a
little confusing the nice thing is when
you're dragging things onto your
dashboard when you hover you should get
a little picture here of what dashboard
what visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all of these called sheet5 sheet
seven you won't know exactly what that
is right away way and so that little
preview is very helpful great profit by
subcategory we'll do the same thing by
removing out all our filters so I just
click on it and hit delete you can also
control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on category as a filter
okay
shell filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you were making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you could make that happen
you could just collect furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this Interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so I'll rename this and call it profit
over time
by category
so we're going to bring on our order
date into columns and it goes to our
discrete value let's change it to our
continuous value so we get that axis
let's grab our profit onto rows and then
mix this align chart we're going to
change that to an area chart an area
chart is nice because when you split it
up by category by dragging category out
of color you can now see what category
is responsible for how much profit like
you do with a line chart however its
area is what defines that so you can see
that area over time and do comparisons
and also it Stacks them on top of each
other so that you can tell that for 2013
our profit was around fifty thousand
dollars really quickly otherwise we have
to add that line this line here and it
makes these lines smaller and lower more
difficult to see so back to our profit
over time by category so that's some of
the benefits of having an area chart and
and if we wanted to go a little more
detailed than here you can hit this plus
and now we have over quarter we have
some negative profits that's interesting
but let's go back to over the Year great
and for this one we're gonna make one
more pie chart so we could start from
scratch or we could duplicate our profit
by region pie chart which I'm going to
do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
it's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region onto text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on tool
tips will affect your level of detail in
the visualization here when it's on tool
tips sometimes it won't change the level
of detail but it could have an effect on
like so if we brought oh let's do this
right now so right now the level of
detail of this chart does not go to the
category by region like it did before
you can bring it on to detail here and
it won't affect color and it won't
affect labels but it will change the
detail and you see how it splits it out
again this is what it would look like if
it's by region by category and you have
much more slices to this pie we'll go
back but if we take region and put it
onto tool tip it's not at a low enough
level for that tool tip to make any
sense so it's going to put that star you
see region is star that's because this
section of the pie covers multiple
regions if we filtered the region to
just Central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when at all
levels it doesn't make any sense but we
won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines is a
big part of what determines how many
slices you get the level of detail for
the whole chart is a big factor as well
on how many slices you get great profit
by region profit by category by
subcategory and by a profit over time
and we have our category filter we don't
have our subcategory filter yet we
grabbed category but let's right click
on subcategory and click show filter
there we go now we have a filter for
category and subcategory
here's our region one we have region in
two places and we don't want that
we wanted to apply it to all of them
we'll do that when we get to the
dashboard
and we have category year of order date
and subcategory great those are all the
filters I wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once I get it set
to the size I want
start with profit by region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that some different space have this at
the bottom have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up next to it
so let's again drag it over to the side
it's always good to pay attention to the
highlighted section and it gives you
kind of an idea oh you see I
accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when I grabbed this I didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all of
these and they happen to be inside the
same section you can come and click
select the layout container and now I'm
grabbing all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what I'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area I'll make that one
floating
this one too
this category Legend applies to both
this chart and this chart so that's very
nice and this subcategory Legend I won't
make floating I'll just put here by
subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now
um because I didn't have to on this
chart and this chart change profit to
dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so I recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so I like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so I take it the
second to the top and I drag the top one
down and then
um category above subcategory just for
logical sense excellent and we have our
profit dashboard let's see there is this
check box down here called show
dashboard title so if we wanted to have
the title at the top here you can click
that button any floating objects don't
shift down like everything else did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title that's up to you
excellent so at this point we have our
overall dashboard that looks at sales
and profit we have our sales dashboard
and we have our profit dashboard our
profit dashboard isn't 100 Complete
because I forgot to make sure all of
these filters apply to all of these
worksheets so let's go ahead and do that
right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook and you
can see the rest here so if you want it
all on the dashboard and you wanted this
one or something like that then you have
the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one year this
area chart becomes a lot less useful but
if you're looking at two or more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard to
our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action so you can make an
action on a worksheet
you can see right here actions or on a
dashboard actions so since we're linking
between two dashboards this is going to
be a dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made but you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the Highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and Define an action it
was made by clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action or when we look on
our sales dashboard we clicked on this
uses filter button so we should have
several actions here that were all
generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click use this filter a highlight
action that we can see from here in
region and go to URL action that we
haven't used if you have any questions
about go to URL please post them in the
comments below it basically allows you
to be able to select a URL here and so
if you had a dashboard that had to do
with maybe stocks you could put in the
URL here and then put your stock ticker
symbol there so that you could have a
URL that would then take you to a
finance website that shows you your
stock information it can get pretty cool
okay but we want to link from this
dashboard to one of our other dashboards
and you actually do that using a filter
action so we're going to name that
action go to sales dashboard and we want
it to happen when we click on our sales
sheet so you see right here it shows us
the two sheets that are on this
dashboard one we click on the profits
dashboard we don't want this action to
occur this is our go to sales dashboard
now you can have an action occur on
Hover or select you've seen select
happen that's what our filter uses
filter actions use and on menu so we're
going to do it on menu and the targeted
sheets it defaults to this dashboard
saying when I click on this I want the
rest of this dashboard to update but
instead it's going to take us to our
sales dashboard
so when we click on this I want these
sheets to update now we're going to
Define what filters it's going to apply
by default it's going to apply all of
the filters based on what we click so if
we click here it will filter to just
2013 let's say we click here it'll
filter to just 2013 and it will filter
to the region we selected so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when I click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and West go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now so we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to over
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here go to
sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now that
happens because it's trying to pass
region information to that dashboard but
this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select What fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and let me go back to that
we click to order date year and it goes
to the Target data source sometimes your
target data source will be a different
data source than the one that you are
using for your Source data source now
that gets a little bit complicated right
now we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this okay and we're gonna add one more
we're gonna add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay if
um One dashboard has region in it and
the other dashboard doesn't have region
in it or doesn't allow you to filter by
region then sometimes you'll get an
error here that will say it's missing
out of your target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard what if
we take out region remove region and
we're just doing it based on year
Okay Okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is so now
it will filter into the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
West it takes you to the dashboard but
it doesn't filter it to West
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to sales let's make one for
profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing where
it's only going to filter it to the year
now you can see oh I started to type in
I didn't show you this before but you
can search text so we started typing in
year and it shows you that under order
date you have all these different
options in this dashboard right now if
you remember we're using the continuous
one that is marked by the little
calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just trading it like a
discrete field okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do is for West here we can select
both years and I'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could put a note in the tooltip for
this that this doesn't work for region
linking from this area doesn't work or
perhaps you could not have this total
line on the same visualization you could
have a separate visualization that shows
the total or an area chart instead and
that will let you not have this problem
of go to sales dashboard not linking
appropriately
so now we're going to create our final
dashboard our segment dashboard and it's
going to use a parameter in it so we'll
get to take a look at parameters on
dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or OK and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same
if we go forward again segment analysis
and profit and sales by segment that
allows you to have some more useful
names down here that make it easy when
you're looking at them side by side but
have a name to match your dashboard up
here great so we're going to make a
profit and sales it's going to be a bars
and circles chart and we're going to
bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet consumer corporate and
home office and then we're going to look
at it segment and we're going to make a
matrix with category and we get to fill
in this space with our visualizations so
we're gonna do sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not synchronizing the
axis now because profit is blue and
these profit is not anywhere near the
same amount as sales which makes sense
you shouldn't have profit that's higher
than sales so let's synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
and it's nice and easy when the two
marks cards are based on a different
measure to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on a bar chart
now if we had profit in front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales another way you can fix it say you
wanted the profit access here over here
for some reason you can right click on
the axis and put Mark type or oh move
marks to fret
another way to change it we don't need
both of these so let's not show that
header and we don't need this to be
labeled profit because it's for both of
them so the way you get rid of that is
actually you click edit access
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes and we have three sets of bar
charts across excellent the next chart
we're going to build oh so right now
they are it automatically added the
colors based on measure names measure
names is a dimension that is created by
Tableau and it's just what it sounds
like we're coloring it based on the
different measure names one of them's
named profit one of them is named sales
and we know that you can come here click
color and hit edit colors and it will
open this dialog box but you can also
come here and double click on a color
pops open that dialog box let's pick a
palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20. let's pick colors from this
palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever and you make it more opaque you
start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
so stick with the Tableau orange blue
great we have our first chart our next
chart is going to be called
top customers Buy sales and this is
where we're going to use our parameter
where we made our top end customers so
let's bring in our set of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set and
so we have our in and our out we're
going to break up our set by our segment
as it's part of our segment analysis and
we'll bring in our customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user friendly title for our users
of this dashboard they're like in and
out of top end customers by sales maybe
we want this to say something a little
bit more user friendly so let's make a
calculated field and we're going to call
it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if and we're
going to use our set top in customers by
sales and since it's an in their outset
it treats this like if it's in top end
customers by sales
then
top
we're going to do a streak so it's going
to be top and then we want to use the
number that's in our parameters so we
have to convert it from a number to a
string and we have to concatenate them
together in Tableau you can use a plus
side top and always make sure you have a
space between what you're concatenating
together that's something that I tend to
forget top space customers so if they
pick 20 it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in this set then top flank
customers else if it's not in the set we
will just call it other and in Tableau
you always need to end your if statement
with an end here it tells us our
calculation is valid while we're here I
want to show you a little trick there's
this arrow button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau and it even sorts It Out by
different categories so if we didn't
know how to make this into a string we
could go to type conversion we could
click on string and it gives you an
example also when you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then I clicked on string and
I'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of Tableau also in Tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press Dash Dash or slash slash and
type in this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's drive profit onto color and you
can see this person has a negative
amount of profit despite their big sales
so that's important for us to know and
we can change our color like we did
previously to go from red to blue
and we can create our Center to zero and
now we can see the negatives really
quickly
no they're not the only one either I
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to show in
or out we just are going to allow them
to show how many but we do want to be
able to have them filtered by category
so let's show that filter and by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen that is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really Dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its Legend and total customers by
sale and it pops up with its Legends and
filters and it pops up with its
parameter now I'm going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are workbook wide meaning
that it's going to exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if I I've changed it to 10
and if I come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why I should name my sheets
let's see if I can find it
nope
here we are sheet 13. in sheet 13
we have our top ten so I've got a 10 and
I've got a 10 over there and if I change
it to 20 and I go back to my segment
dashboard it is also changed to 20. so
it will affect all sheets always very
important to know great so here's our
visualization here are some of the more
useful Legends so let's make this
floating and put it over by the
visualization it matters for we can do
the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these effects all the
dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating Legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
Developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
Tableau we talked about how to install
Tableau public and how to connect to a
data source
we also talked about creating calculated
Fields like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between Dash
welcome to Tableau training part two we
will be learning about the topics we
discussed in part one live versus
extract data sources we'll talk about
joins and unions and we'll look at table
calculations we'll look at the rank
functions and we'll look at actions
specifically URL actions we'll talk
about reference lines and bands we'll
look into some insights in the data such
as delay analysis also we'll learn how
to build a waterfall chart and then
finally we will learn about level of
detail calculations while making two
different visualizations
in part one of this Tableau training we
introduced Tableau Basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards now let's discuss the
difference between a live connection and
an extract connection first it's
important to note that these different
types of connections are not available
in Tableau public it's always a live
connection and a live connection is
where the data will update based on when
the source of the data updates so if any
if you're connected to a database and
something in the database changes then
you'll pick up those changes when you
open the report as it will query that
database when the report is opened
whereas an extract connection is
extracted into creates a subset of the
data that improves performance so when
you're looking at it locally on your
computer you have an extract of that
data set that subset of the data right
on your computer or up in Tableau server
depending on where you're looking at it
and it does not update when the the
database updates it only updates when
you're refresh updates it so without a
refresh set for that extract you won't
get the new data as an example of this
let's say that in our sample superstore
we have Kelly Williams associated with
the central region but that's changed so
let's go ahead and change that
we will change it to
Sarah Smith and
we'll save it now let's go back to our
Tableau workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see Sarah Smith come in over
here in our extract it Sarah Smith
doesn't come in if we cook to refresh
the extract it doesn't refresh the
extract until we navigate to sheet1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see Sarah Smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day or once every
several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get Sarah
Smith's data coming in next let's talk
about joining data in Tableau so here we
have the people table but let's say we
want to join it to our orders
information so I'm going to start with
our orders table and then we're going to
pull on people and Tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then Tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what to to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side and the people
side what we'd like to join on and then
we have the options to do an inner join
a left join a right join and a full
outer join let's review quickly what
these look like so say we had two tables
that we wanted to join together one of
them was the student table that had the
student names and the key to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade ABCD F and incomplete we
can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
um and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at so if we were to do an
inner join
that would only take the rows where the
join could complete so we have one that
could join to one just fine but we don't
have two and we don't have three a
doesn't join to anything so this row
would be not included and then four five
and six would all join so that would
look something like this where we would
see Adam when we grab student from this
table and grade from this table we can
see Adam had an a that really had an a
Dale had a d Elizabeth had an f and
Frank is incomplete and Charles is
missing also you don't see any B or C in
this list of grades for a left join it's
going to take everything
from the left table and only the pieces
from the right table that apply to the
left table so it looks pretty similar to
our inner join only Charles shows up so
the join wasn't able to complete since a
doesn't exist in grade but we include
Charles anyways and grade becomes null
for Charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and then returns null we look up
a inside the grade key Perfect Right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table so it grabs all the
grades a b c d f and incomplete and only
the rows from the left table that join
appropriately so since Charles isn't
joined appropriately he doesn't show up
we also have B and C showing up even
though it doesn't exist in the student
table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer Joy
where it takes everything from both
tables whether or not the join is
complete complete so we have all of the
people where the join completes we also
have Charles where the join doesn't
complete from the left to the right and
we have B and C where the join doesn't
complete from the right to the left so
those are our options in tableau
here in our sample Superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is not in the people
table that's when you would do a left
joint
for our purposes we'll do an inner join
now let's say we had a second Excel
sheet here that had more orders and you
can do a union which is just adding more
orders by dragging that second order's
table right underneath the original
orders table you can see it says their
drag table to Union and that's helpful
for if you have an Excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate Excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to Union and it would take
these orders and then add the rows
instead of the columns for the 2016
orders
for example we've added people but as a
join and that will first put in all of
our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order columns so it would
have the same data the same order ID
ship date but we wanted to add more rows
then that would be when you Union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category we also have percentage of
total sales along table down so the
difference between these two things are
one of them is made using
the calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales which basically makes the database
find the total sum of sales regardless
of these Dimensions we pulled on so it
gives us our total number so this will
be sum of sales for bookcases and this
will be some of sales for everything
this calculation is done on the database
side whereas this one percentage of
total sales a long table down is what's
called a table calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done in
Tableau it's processed locally right
inside of the table after the
aggregations have occurred there are
some pros and cons of doing it this way
so for this percent of total sales
I had to create the table calculation
here and it does the fixed sum of sales
where it finds the sum of sales for the
entire database and since it is fixed it
will ignore filters so for example I
took off both of the sales and I'm just
going to put on the percent sum of sales
and let's say we wanted to see how
office supplies and Technology are as
percentages of sum of sales and ignore
Furniture so we can grab category and
we'll control click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit OK
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
whereas if we take sales
and double click it and it adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation and
click
percent of total this one is doing it
out of 100 and these numbers don't match
and that's because it does take into
account the filter of category so let's
pull the filter category off and we can
see that they're both out of a hundred
percent now and each of these take into
account
um the same amount of data since we have
no filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table then you need
to use a table calculation however when
you push the information back to the
database to do the calculation it's
doing it as part of the query to the
data source and it can save you some
time and so which one of these is faster
sort of depends on what data is
available already when the original
query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
Tableau first let's add a second data
source so we can do that by coming up to
data and clicking new data source or you
can just click this Plus data source
right here and click Microsoft Excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store pull on sales and we will
rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them based on who had the
highest sales to the lowest sales we
could create a calculated field
ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank function
and we're going to put it in sales now
we receive this error here so when we
hover we see what that Arrow says oh you
can click and it says all Fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated so
we can make some
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when I click on rank it
will tell us that it Returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row and it says identical values
are assigned identical rank so let's see
what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on Rank by sales and
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one D is next and
c and b are tied 20 and 20.
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place but
now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these we'll
click duplicate
and edit let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense Returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click OK double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five it goes one two three four so
it doesn't include that Gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe I want it to be in the order I
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that'll move sales to the front and
put rank dents at the bottom so now we
can see sales we can see Rank by sales
we rank dense by sales
now let's duplicate
and look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that I
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists this Tableau won't allow you to
use the same name
foreign
so those errors can be pretty helpful in
finding out what's going on hit apply
and okay and then double click rank
Modified by sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on ring
modified and it says it Returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by Rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both received the same rank
here but they received the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
people
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank uni
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click like unique and we
have one two three four and five so what
it's doing is let's quickly look here so
Rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you'll
Define so right it defaults to
descending and it's saying the biggest
is the best
so in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do four and it's doing
that based on the ASCII values of the
store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase B comes
before lowercase C uppercase B is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data and
we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in Tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before in our Tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask in the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at category so we'll drag
category onto columns and then we're
going to look at sales so we'll drag
sales onto rows and it will create three
bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
on two rows again
and let's take
subcategory and bring it on to color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to move from the sales
by category sheet to the sales by
subcategory sheet and also filter down
that sheet to only the category we want
to see
so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list and which sheets
do we want to affect we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other data source if we click rank
example it will show the rank example
data source so we just want sales by
category to be the source sheet and the
target sheet we want it to be sales by
subcategory
so on select we want it to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available to create this filter
and hit OK so now we have our go to
subcategory on select we'll hit OK again
and let's make this a little wider so we
can see and so when we click on
furniture it will take us to Only
Furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make Tableau drill to a lower
level
thank you
great so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions you can see that we have the
action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category two let's
say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category 2.
and hit OK and hit okay now when we go
to worksheet actions
now you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory great so we have
our sales by category two let's bring it
to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories in the colors there
now we can take a look here
and sort by subcategory based on some of
sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just a way
that I like to view it so let's do a
highlight action and we're going to do
it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory and look at it over top of
our sales by category stacked over top
of sales by sap category so we want both
of those let's make our dashboard
automatic for
testing purposes and we'll go to
dashboard we'll click create actions so
we're going to add an action it's going
to be a highlight action
highlight sales by
subcategory
foreign
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by subcategory be the target
sheet for all Fields okay okay and on
select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization a cool thing you can
do is you could select office supplies
here and it will highlight all of office
supplies or if you drag and select a
couple of them it will show you those so
you're just like I want to see all these
small ones or I want to see this one and
these small ones or whatever then it
will highlight the ones that you drag
and select now this is also true of our
sales by subcategory and sales by
category so when we clicked on
technology it filtered to just
technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click office supplies and Technology we
get office supplies and Technology now
if we go back to the dashboard we can
see that this dashboard is now filtered
also to office supplies and technology
and that's because we're using the same
sheet and when you navigate away from
that sheet it doesn't mean that your
filter goes away
so when I click undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so if
you're going to have two things affect
that sheet just remember that just
because you navigated away from what you
selected doesn't mean that what you
selected goes away that filter will stay
there and it shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a URL action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so I'm going to double click State
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a filled map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put State onto label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label so we can
see the sales amount let's quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're going to lose the decimal
places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on great so now we have our sales map
and we're going to create
uh worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're going to make a go to URL
action we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it Wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet
six which we should rename and we're
going to have a URL in here so this will
take us to Wikipedia and then whatever
you put at the end of the Wikipedia link
it will take you to that page on
Wikipedia so we're going to take State
and add it to the end of that link and
now to test the link you can just click
test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up Okay click OK let's
rename our sheet to
URL
filter by state and so when we click on
Texas okay back to URL filter by state
let's go to our worksheets
and what are our actions and on the go
to subcategory
is also affecting this URL filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here in sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it will Auto Select new sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on Texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on Texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on Wiki and it
will open up our browser with the
Wikipedia page for Texas this can become
really handy in the event that you have
data that maybe has an order ID and you
can take that order ID and insert it
into a URL in your system so that it can
take you to your web interface page for
that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of California
which um it can have information about
the languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
Tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filter by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to URL action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this URL won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our Wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on Oklahoma
it'll open up a page for Oklahoma
but let's unselect Oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit OK and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on Oklahoma
instead of taking us to Oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to Oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to Texas and this will change to Texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
line
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics Pane and it is something that
comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so let's make our
visualization we'll do our category and
sub category again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it on to text that's not
what I want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pain and the table so when we
go to Analytics
and we code to drag our reference line
onto our visualization it says you can
add the reference line for the whole
table for a pane or for a cell so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to Define our cell so
each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto
sell each one of them gets a reference
line you see how it added those on this
is our dialog box we will look at that
in just a moment so let's remove that if
we take reference line and put it onto
pane
that's going to be similar to having
category and a color so each of these
different colors is now a pain
reference line onto pain and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it on to table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do find out the
average for each section so I'm going to
take category and put it back onto color
and we'll take reference line and put it
onto pane now we have our reference line
it's based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it is taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs so it's taking an average across
these added up sections
you could also have it be total where
it's adding all of these up and it makes
that total line
the stem line is the same as total in
this case a constant which is where you
get to define the value and so if we
wanted it to be 200
there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average or the median so let's
stick with average and now you can see
it's labeling the line as average we
could also have it label the line as the
value so now we can see that the average
is this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon and then the value average this
amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on a
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
OK and so in that case when we click on
tables
you can see our recalculated average
line
so the average for tables for just
tables is the sum divided by the number
so the sum of tables is 206 966 divided
by one is still 206.966. so selecting
just tables isn't really helpful but if
we wanted to know the average of tables
and we'll control click appliances and
we'll control click binders oh there we
go all three of those are selected we
can see the average of those three which
is this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
select these guys and now we see the
average of just those five categories
and those are reference lines now let's
duplicate this sheet
and I'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
bands
click on this reference line right click
and click remove and it takes it off we
have the same thing for reference bands
we had with reference lines where you
can have it be for the whole table per
pane or per cell so let's do a reference
band for the whole table so it's doing
entire table and it's taking from the
minimum to the maximum now we could
change the minimum to be the average to
the maximum and now that will highlight
the whole table everything that's above
the average becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you could add lines so we have a
line for the average or the maximum you
can make it thinner you can make it
dotted you can change your fill so maybe
if you don't want it to be quite that
dark you can change it to be a little
bit of a lighter color of gray and you
can have show recalculated band for
highlighted or you can remove that and
that way when we highlight stuff
everything just stays where it belongs
for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making several
different kinds of visualizations such
as bullet charts if you have any
questions about that please comment
below and the simply learned team will
get back to you now let's do another
analysis on average days to ship
and for this one we're going to look at
it by state
and we're going to look at it by ship
mode
and so we'll take average there's a ship
and put it on columns and now we can see
the average days to ship by first class
same day second class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's change the
order of these really quick if we come
up here to ship mode and we click sort
and we click manual we can have same day
above first class so that it kind of
goes in order of priority so same day
first class second class standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do if the
average days ship is less than or equal
to two
then we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter you
could have extra spaces and it won't a
tableau will ignore those so this allows
us to format our calculated field in a
way that's easy to read so if it's less
than two then they're going to call it
an early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to five
then shipment
complete
and else if let's get the rest of them
and average days of ship is not less
than two
greater than two
and less than five
then on time
on time
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if that
means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement if
statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it onto color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment as orange and shipment
linked as red
we could double click on the color and
we can change shipment early to Green
and now we can see the best ones the
on-time ones and the ones that stand out
as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the District of Columbia
has second class as a late shipment
you can see that all of these
share the same access size so they all
go from zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to Six
if we click edit axis you can choose if
you want that to be the case so it's
like right now all of them use uniform
access range for all rows or columns and
that's really nice because it's easy to
compare Colorado to Colorado to Colorado
if you change it to Independent access
for each rows you can see now this one
only goes from zero to not even one
whereas this one goes from zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall looks like at the end and talk
about how it works so after we build it
we'll talk about some of the benefits of
having a waterfall chart so what we're
going to do is build it over time for
this visualization we're just going to
look at the year of 2014 so I'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014.
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month so you can see that I
chose the one that has month and year
and then when I chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from profit to our running
total of profit
so you can see that it takes January and
then it adds February to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to where we have our running total
where it will some January and February
for the February Mark and then some
January February March for the March
mark
if I take profit
and put it here you can see January is
negative 3000 and February is positive
two thousand but here it's the sum of
those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a Gant bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have we're going to
call this negative
profit
and it's going to be just profit with
the negative side in front
oh it looks like I've done this before
so now we have a new name because I
added a space at the end so hit apply
and let's um delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative Profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit and we're going to use that to
determine the size
of the Gant bar so what it does is it
takes where the line was and it adds the
size of it to be the size of profit but
because the line was at the top and we
didn't want to build the profit up we
had to change it to negative profit so
it would build it down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are November
and March November being a little bit
bigger and you can see where we started
at the beginning of that month and where
we ended and that's how a waterfall
chart works so it lets you go through
over time and see exactly where our
problems were and exactly which months
helped the most where we started and
where we ended for each month next we're
going to talk about level of detail
calculation and we'll talk about those
first by showing an example so I'm going
to bring all my customers on
by name and then I'm going to bring on
order ID
and it's going to add all members but
then I'm going to change order ID from a
dimension to a measure and we have a
count distinct so now we can see each
customer and how many orders they have
so let's sort it and we can see one
person has 17 orders and we have one two
three four five six seven
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show how many
customers had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization and bring on
metrics that are at a level that is
different from what's shown on the
visualization so
in order to do this we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us the number of orders
per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer so let's
call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are two other level of detail
calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in some of our simply learned classes
and if you have any questions please
comment below and we can answer them so
we're going to do a fixed and you can
choose
dimensions and they could compute the
aggregation using only the specified
Dimensions so it'll ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order ID
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors I
will hit okay
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see one two three four
five six seven eight up to 17. so that
means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers order 17 and we had them order
everything in between so if we never had
a customer that had nine orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer ID or
name
let's do ID because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure and it's
going to be account distinct and so now
we can see
how many customers ordered how many
items
so we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail LOD
ders per customer
perfect now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to do an analysis about
new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time we're going
to use these
so that it makes an axis instead of just
change it to line instead of Dimensions
or something that is not continuous and
then we're going to take our customer ID
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
kind of distinct customer ID and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day I think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month
let's take region
and split it out by region
we click on Central we can see Central
now this is including all customers but
say we only wanted to include a customer
when they're making their very first
order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
now we want to compare their order date
per customer
foreign
to their first order date the Min order
date
nope
order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per Road level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on the visualization
and it won't let you put those two
things together so we're going to
use our level of detail calculation
again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer ID
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of trying to return
something different based on the
visualization it will always return the
Min for each customer ID so if the order
date on the visualization is equal to
this order date
yeah the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
foreign
new
else
existing
end
so when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that the new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date apply okay and now we can take our
new field
which is new or existing drag it on the
filters and we only want new we'll hit
apply
and we can see that we have new
customers but less over time
so
so now we're going to change this count
distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time how our new customers are
adding up so it's taking the prior value
and adding our new customers and then at
the end we get our total customers for
each region and we can now make this a
more
the lowest level which is day and you
can see places where it like levels out
so we can see we have a lot of new
customers and it's increasing but then
here for the region of East there kind
of is a level spot where we're not
getting new orders and that seems to be
the same for each of them so for
February of 2014 why were we not getting
any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red it
looks like the west region leveled out
as well but picked up sooner and started
getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view new customers over time and it's
only possible because we were able to do
a level of detail calculation here on
new or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified Dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
in summary today we learned about live
versus extract Tableau Data sources we
learned about joins and unions in the
data sources we also looked at table
versus database calculations we looked
at how the different ranks compare we
built some actions into our dashboards
filter actions and highlighting actions
we also looked at URL actions we built
dashboards that used reference lines and
ones that use reference bands we did
analyzing of average days to ship and
delay analysis we build a waterfall
chart and we also looked into some level
of detail calculations we will be
building dashboards from start to finish
first about world population then Health
next we'll build a dashboard about
economy and finally we'll build a
dashboard about business ease I would
recommend getting access to the data set
before you start this tutorial so you
can build along with me if you would
like access to this data set please
comment below and we'll get you access
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build a map
based on Country so I'm going to double
click on country and it's going to map
out all of the countries and then on our
marks I'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map but we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see who contributes the most
to population we're going to label it
with population as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is how much it contributes to
population by percentage so let's add a
table calculation and we're going to
have it do percent of total
based on country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label and let's put it on top so
country names on top now it's getting a
little bit of crowded in here so
we're going to unclick show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that we want to see specifically so when
we can right click on China here hover
on Mark label and click always show
and on India
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here
and that's just a manual way to choose
which ones have indicators labels and
which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate
an area
that explains that
China and India
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so year with the
calendar Mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to a discrete version so let's take it
back off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on a
Windows machine if you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis and we're going
to bring on population total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high in your axis is you can
uncheck this box that says include zero
and it will not always include zero in
your axis but this can be misleading so
you can see that it looks like
population growth is something really
dramatic by increasing that slope of the
Y
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated well and you're not doing
it to
mislead your users you just need to keep
in mind that this includes xero can
change what your graph is saying so
we're going to not include the zero at
this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're going to click on forecast and
drag it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
NC forecast result is actual and
forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change it says automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and
we'll go out into the future up to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals okay and then you can also
have your trendline show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
foreign
population
excellent we're going to make one more
visualization for this and it's going to
be a pie chart so the pie chart is also
going to be based off of population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
and click your pie chart
great so I'm going to make this the
entire view so we can see the
pen this is getting really crazy in here
so I have changed my mind and instead of
country I'm going to drag region over
top of country and now we see something
a little bit more manageable so we can
see that here's Asia
and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total and we
could keep it that way or we could
do what we did last time and change it
to percent of total so that on Hover we
can see the population and the
percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to show Asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these
and we're going to right click and click
group
so now we have all those things we
selected and we have other let's edit
our group right click edit group
we're going to rename this group
Asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group the rest of
the world
okay so now we have our group we can
drag it on to label now we can see Asia
and rest of the world and now see how
it's breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on our detail right here so we
pull region off now it's just split Asia
rest of the world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
and we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
great so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and we have a range which has a minimum
size and a maximum size some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will felt screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right if you have automatic
then it will fit the screen that it's
displayed on however the things that
you've placed might get squished too
close together and then the range gives
you a minimum size and a maximum size
meaning if the screen is too big it
still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens you at least
know that it will never make it get
smaller than this particular size so
there's some benefits to that as well
where you still have a little bit of
control of what it will look like in the
end great let's bring on our worksheets
be that way you hover it fills up that
space and that's where it's going to
show up you can also adjust the lines in
between different visualizations for
things that need more space or less
space another important thing to
recognize is that when you click on a
visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard Fit
versus if you have entire view where it
will make it fit into inside the box
over here we could have fit width
or fit height on some of the
visualizations it doesn't make as much
of a difference however when you have a
visualization that maybe has a lot of
text in it and they need to be able to
scroll you'll want to have it fit width
but you don't want it to fit height
because then it will shove all of that
information into the box and not allow
you to scroll up and down
so if you saw as we drag these on it
took these
Legends and added it to the left here we
can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
it has a couple of things wrong with it
we might not want the title of this to
be region group so we could come in and
we could edit the title and then
maybe just call it region
however I don't think we need this
Legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again is unnecessary potentially because
we have our two population numbers
showing upright as we hover
to remove that as well so at this point
we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here one of the quickest things you can
do to add functionality to the dashboard
is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now that uses filter button actually
creates an action here filter one
generated that it's made on its own now
you can see that when we click on China
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
China click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
20 or the 20 here and the 17
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows 100 because it's
filtered everything else out of the
chart so it now makes up 100 of the
circle so that doesn't make a lot of
sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions modify your actions so that they
only affect the things that make sense
so we can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify only the trend
so now when we click on
China we see China's Trend over time
and it doesn't affect our pie
because that doesn't make sense for it
to affect our pie
we might want to select on our pie
Asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
Asia and now it zooms into Asia on our
map
and shows us just the Asia world
population Trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that Asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
trend
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use filter
then we click on 2011.
you can see these numbers are slightly
updating so this is 19 percent
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pi updates a little bit although it
hasn't been anything dramatic you kind
of see it over time
so that's one way to add filters to your
visualization another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our Trend we could take the year we're
going to control click and drag it onto
filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time or a
range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider from 2000 to 2012. so if we
hit OK
we'll right click and we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so it could remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years so let's drag
year onto the filters we're just going
to do the year number next
and here's all the years we're going to
let all of them be selected for now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up and we can make it like
a drop down so they can still select
multiples but it's a drop down or maybe
we want this visualization to be just
one year at a time so we can choose
single value in a list and it lists out
all the years or in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012.
and then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year over
year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so I tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what I publish
so we're going to single value drop down
we're going to
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are come here to
layout
see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container we
have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this View
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side and a vertical container
allows things to be a one on top of the
other and so in our vertical container
we see all this extra space for extra
things to be on top of each other but if
we wanted to have it at the top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was even though all the other things
shifted so that's one of the
disadvantages of floating is that you're
kind of just manually choosing
where it will stand
using your X and Y position
and it's not Dynamic so let's give this
a little bit less space up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container or we'll say
copy
animation dashboard
we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you give it more or less space
bring our Legends down to places where
they make sense again
perfect and so now we have this that
will affect this
only and show you just 2012 2011 2010.
so we don't want it to affect the trend
because we want the trend to show
all of time and just looking at one year
for this trend that is only at a yearly
part and forecasts into the future
doesn't make any sense but we maybe
wanted to also affect this worksheet so
that these two are in sync and so the
dashboard is basically for 2012 except
for the trend which shows you the
opacity in the future so one way that
you can do that is clicking apply to
worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization or in this
dashboard and you can click show all
worksheets in workbook and then if there
were other worksheets it would show them
so we wanted to do Asia versus rest of
the world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to click on a country and have it make
the change if we instead want to have a
filter for Country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters
we'll have it show off for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and at
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filter so that's
a nice feature of Tableau where it can
kind of guess where you might want
things we're going to do multiple value
drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we wanted to affect the world
population Trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing I like to do on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see I've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
I wanted to look at Turkey so I found
turkey and then I hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some Legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user I
press escape and get back out and it
doesn't give you these highlights when
you hover over things that are dashboard
formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away and it just gives you the
opportunity to test out your dashboard
in a more real way and see how they will
use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing option options next we're going
to make a dashboard revolving around
health information so first we're going
to make a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and
we're going to change it to a map type
so we have a filled map here and then
we're going to bring birth rate onto
color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is more
associated with countries that have poor
health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our higher birth rate
countries highlighted in red next we're
going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized it has having an alarming
birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to do a rank on
that
do you see sometimes
when you're Auto completing your
statements it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if I type if or I start to type if and
then I come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because I was typing it
right next to it so if I put a space and
then I start to type if and I click if
it will not delete rank so we're gonna
say if the rank of average is less than
or equal to 50. so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we could take this again
is greater than 50 then
normal over 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases so with these if statements just
make sure that you're always getting all
the different options
that you want but in this case we
defined both however we didn't have to
define the second calculation because if
it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom
so we're going to hit OK and then we're
going to put birth rate class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and I am seeing alarming birth rate on
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by
right-clicking and clicking edit you can
see it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit OK and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place I would look if it's
not doing what you would expect
so
we'll put it back to automatic okay the
second place I would look is inside of
the table calculation that is created so
when we defined rank here we put a table
calculation on it so when we right click
here we get edit table calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rate we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and
we are done here but one thing you could
do is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that every label shows up but it
gets super crazy in there so there are
some times where the labels May overlap
a little bit and so you'll want to
select this option in our case we don't
want that
and now we have a visualization
showing
birth rate map based on rank our next
visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do a chart across time
so we're going to click year and bring
it on two columns and we're going to
change it to this year in the continuous
section so now we have an axis
and
we're going to double click on female
life expectancy up there we go double
click on female life expectancy and then
double click on mail life expectancy so
what that did was made us two charts put
one on top of the other but we don't
want that so we'll take this off and
we're going to drag nail life expectancy
right onto this axis for the female life
expectancy
and what this is done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended access chart so they
necessarily use the same axes and they
necessarily have the same kinds of marks
so we'll take a look and see what the
difference is there so if I were to
change this to a bar chart we would have
bar chart for both of them and I can't
Define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart now if we
go back to when we just had female life
expectancy and we drag male on next to
it and we have two charts now we can
change it to a dual axis and we have one
on top of the other however our axes
don't line up we can see at the top here
is 15K and over here it's 14k so we're
going to synchronize the accent and you
can see
one on top of the other
and we have two marks cards so we could
have this one be a bar chart and that
would be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
access chart so I'm going to take mail
and drag it here
and we have our Blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here is
really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since I only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's drag on forecast so it's
forecasted out the next two years for
both line
and we'll bring on Trent
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see each
individual point for the life expectancy
for our females and males and we can see
what they're expected to be in the
future and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different measures so we'll
just call it a heat map for now and for
our heat map we're going to look at the
different countries so we'll bring
country onto rows and we're going to
look at their
birth rate
so I just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
GDP so how much they spend on GDP
so when I double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measured names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values Define what's in the text right
here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate and the life
expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate we definitely want to
have
decimals afterwards as a matter of fact
the birth rate is a percentage so
instead of doing a number standard we'll
just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate and for
percent of GDP for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the full for all of these we could
change it from a sum to an average in
the default properties under aggregation
so that will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
I won't do that at this time because I
get a little bit confused sometimes when
I don't have my thumb on there um by
default because that's what I'm so used
to seeing by default great so we now
have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values and drag it on
to color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors Darkly the higher the
number it is in this case and right now
it's doing it for the whole area so one
percent is obviously much much smaller
than 82. but if we wanted to be able to
look at birth rate independently from
life expectancy we can right click on
the measure values on the color and
click use separate Legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those Legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends and
we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color two another
color we used the
Red Gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also Define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from light to dark and then you can
choose what color you want as your dark
color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
bending for on health
and that is our heat map
with separate Legends so let's build
this all into a dashboard now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for Simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates then we're
going to bring on our heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our Legends here
and we're going to move our Legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
foreign
container
and then let's put our Legends
into the horizontal container
and let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh so birth rate is going to be over
here
great now one thing we can do is make
these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay
so it would make them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width so once you start to
drag the size on something it no longer
is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one is not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be even bigger
then I will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be now let's take a look at
filters oh before we take a look at
filters I want to look at this map one
more time because I think that it would
be useful for our colors to be a little
bit more
distinct so one quick way to navigate to
your worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button and while
we're here I'm going to click on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from this
sequence to a stepped color
now we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be this
color this color this color I want to
hit OK
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic in our differences and
it's put everything into the three
categories we defined so let's go back
to our dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
foreign we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard which ones aren't
and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're going to hit OK
now we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
allow them to
choose years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year because we want
to be able to see it over time and if we
filter down the time then we don't get
as much context so we'll hit OK
let's go back to our dashboard
if I click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because I told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
I made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
see I wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
I clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now we get the year of year
as well so we'll click year of year
let's put it over here
and we're going to make it
multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it
even smaller
200.
great and let's change our country
to be a single value drop down so you
can pick one at a time and let's also
change it or this year of year since we
can select multiples let's change it so
that
on customize that you show the apply
button so here since they can only
select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since I can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years and then hit apply and then
you'll see the changes and you can see
that even though I've selected only 2011
and 2012 you still see all the years on
this line chart as expected
and there is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy our first sheet is going
to be
another map that is going to have to do
with overall GDP
and as we usually begin with maps by
double clicking on country
and changing it to a map Mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
GDP onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do a custom diverging so
you get to pick both colors and let's
pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay red for there and then we want to
do maybe like a deeper green and that
way you can see who has the highest GDP
which is green we hit apply okay and
then it will eventually get lighter and
lighter until it goes to gray which then
it will lead to Green
okay
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call GDP versus GDP per
capita
so
GDP or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis
and then another measure which is going
to be
GDP per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with GDP and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that and we're going to
call it
GDP per capita
and we're going to take
some
of GDP
and divided by the sum
of the total
population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis there we go
and then we have GDP per capita so
what's what this will do is sum up the
GDP
across whatever measures we have in
place I will cross whatever Dimensions
we have in place and then sum up the
population for those same dimensions and
then divide it instead of dividing it
per row and then
doing an aggregation on it
so now we're going to bring on GDP per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of GDP and the GDP
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little Mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one Mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high GDP per capita and some countries
have a high GDP overall but not as high
of a GDP per capita
so on we have some middle of the road
people here so we can change this from
automatic to circles and now they're
dots like you might see on a scatter
plot and you can
drag region
onto color and now we can see our
different regions
and see we see a lot of Reds here
and
it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the Americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing how much countries spend on
Health Care
as a part of their GDP so we're going to
rename it
to be GDP on Healthcare
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense GDP
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show the health
expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on GDP
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their GDP on health we can
again bring region onto color so we can
see the different regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this and drag it onto the labels
and we can see that it's a percentage
but it's coming up as a number so we can
right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control and drag
that onto labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure necessarily what
currency this data set is in
um it's worth checking out what currency
it is in so for now we'll just have it
as a number
and now we're going to customize our
tool tip so we're going to go to the
overall marks card
and we'll click on tooltip and we wanted
to tell us the country in the top so
we're a race region
and we're going to
erase country label in Center country
and then we're going to put
this country
bends
this percentage
on Healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example of Marshall
Island spends 2.1 percent on Health Care
we'll hit enter and then when we hover
tells you the country and it has our
Custom Tool tip on both visualizations
or on both
of the different axes
so let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
Healthcare
visualization
and our GBP versus GDP per capita
and we'll move our Legends to the top
again by adding a horizontal container
to the top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these Legends are just side by side
just above the nap
and the GDP per capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
Tableau is you can see this outlier of
the United States is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any Trends there so
you could right click on it and click
exclude and then it will exclude it from
your data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all okay
now we're going to apply it to
worksheets so I showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply it to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see that
countries on the filters for this
visualization but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see some country because it's
in the details of the information so
either way when we add country
since I added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a URL action add action go to URL
and when we click on a country on the
overall GDP map we want it to take us to
the Wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country so that is
this URL and it's going to say Wikipedia
for economy of
now we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit OK
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it
and we can click on Canada
and it will take us to the Wikipedia
page for the economy of Canada
great I'm gonna click on Brazil same
thing
so if we unselect on Brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations and so we could
click use this filter here and then when
we click on France it will filter these
two other visualizations to France
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
Germany
Germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click France and
Germany and Switzerland
and Austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest GDP is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization when you
publish it to server or you can deal
with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business
so how many days it takes to start a
business is important to know when
you're trying to start a business in a
country and also can be an indicator of
how easy it will be to do business in
that country so let's make a bar chart
that includes every country and then
we're going to bring on days to start a
business
and we will sort it smallest to biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to filter it to only
those that have a good Market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to Define business Friendly
Market
well
we're going to Define our Market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25 then
relative
they used to start a business is greater
than 25 then
business
might or might not
work
doing by less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to Define these two
different markets so we'll hit apply
there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good Market
and we're going to look at
just one year
we'll look at 2012.
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region and we can see which regions tend
to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to move on and build our
next visualization which is also a bar
chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we could bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it a measure so the ease of
business is at this point looking at it
like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum but if we here convert it to a
measure then it also automatically made
it a count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do like the sum
of ease of business
in our use case we're actually going to
do the average of ease of business and
then we want to have the smallest on the
top we do have some that don't have ease
of business ratings so we're going to
filter that data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select easy business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and we're going to segment this by
creating another header
we're going to call that
business friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is so I guess this is a nice thing to
know so if if we start typing in what we
want to see then we can select it from a
list here but you can also interact
outside of this box so you could just
grab these of business and drag it into
the dialog box here and that's really
nice so we're going to say if it is
greater than or equal to one
and less than or equal to
three
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement will work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an n
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this if statement
goes through one condition at a time so
it's already classified everything
that's between these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business is
less than or equal to 10.
then
we'll call it very very business
friendly regulations
and we'll keep going
else if ease of business is less than or
equal to 50 then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
copy that for later use
less than equal to 150 then
strict
so the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because these sections one to
three and then three or well four to ten
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred for
business
see if we get any errors calculation is
valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply and we'll
bring business friendly onto our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so we want to
Define what order these go in so we're
going to click sort and we want the most
business friendly at the top
then we want moderate then strict than
not preferred okay so we have our top
three that are the most business
friendly and then we've got four through
ten which are very then we've got our
moderate
our strict
and are not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there and
now we're going to make this even more
useful by adding the business tax rate
onto the label so that you can see that
business friendly
is like Singapore but they have a pretty
high tax rate of 27 whereas if you get
down to some of these that are not
preferred some of them have really low
tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like Saudi Arabia
and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that segment decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay now let's make some annotations so
we could come and click here on this
Mark and then we can annotate that Mark
which will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here and so we could
use some of this information so I'm
going to copy that
and I'll put some in hard returns there
so we're going to say that this country
is the most
business friendly but has a
business tax rate of and let's grab the
tax rate
and then We'll erase this
and we'll hit okay
and I've made a typo so Singapore is the
most business friend is not what I meant
to say so I can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around draws the line to Singapore
which is the mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a Mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
often have
High
is this taxes
change that size make everything fit
now we have this second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our axis
now we're going to look at mobile phone
usage so I double clicked it it shows
mobile phone usage over time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries and then we're going to bring
on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to also make that
average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently and so we can make it a
dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their rates however the
uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and then move that onto the front Okay
and now it's made each of these wide and
there's like a start point and end point
on the axis for the bar and that comes
here under size where they're all fixed
or you could have it be manual where we
can Define the size of the bars so we're
going to make those bars like this
now we can see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to Orange
since red might apply that it's bad
In some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that I have a sheet called
to use as a business and a dashboard
that I've called is a business but it
won't let you create a dashboard with
the same name
so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and we're going to bring on our
days to start business visual
our ease of business visual
and our phone and internet visual
let's put our Legends at the top again
so I'll make our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region Legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
2011. so let's see why that's happening
if we go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show filter
and if we change the filter to 2011 okay
it's not showing up here and the only
filter I can see that could be removing
it is this average use of business
that is removing anything that is null
so if I pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years I select I'm not
seeing any ease of business information
so
we are going to want to set this to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so let's go back until we're back to the
state we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
and we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
that only selects 2012.
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change year view it only
changes this visualization sometimes
that's useful to note sometimes it's
useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like here
that makes it clear that it's just
changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great
and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter and that
way we can click on New Zealand and we
can see it's a most business friendly
regulations and we can see it's internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper change so
some of them have adopted phone and
internet usage and have stayed pretty
similar how whereas other ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet I click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop-out Arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
and we can bring country on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that if we just want to
look at Afghanistan
okay
we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are
four dashboards
board dashboard on population
we made one about health we made one
that had to do with our economy and one
that had to do with our ease of doing
business business intelligence is a set
of processes and techniques to analyze
raw data and extract information that
helps Drive business decisions it helps
you keep track of business data and draw
valuable insights there are several
tools that play a key role in business
intelligence some of the popular tools
are power bi Tableau and view hi
guys welcome to this tutorial on what is
power bi in this video you will learn
why power bi is needed what is power bi
the various features of power bi and the
different components of power bi later
you will look at the architecture of
power bi what power bi services and how
to create a power bi dashboard finally
you will understand a case study on
Meyer and do a demo using power bi now
let's understand why power bi is needed
first Power bi has the ability to access
vast volumes of data from multiple
sources it allows you to view analyze
and visualize huge quantities of data
that cannot be opened in Excel some of
the important data sources available in
power bi are Excel CSV XML Json PDF Etc
second power bi provides an easy to use
drag and drop tool with features and
functionalities that allow you to copy
all formatting across similar
visualizations power bi has exceptional
integration with Excel it helps you
gather analyze publish and share Excel
business data power bi helps to
accelerate Big Data preparation with
Azure using power bi with Azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data as your data Lake can reduce the
time it takes to get insights and
increase collaboration between business
analysts data engineers and data
scientists power bi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into actions to take data-driven
business decisions finally power bi
allows you to perform real-time stream
analytics it fetches data from multiple
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real-time analytics so you are
always ready to make business decisions
now let's see what power bi is power bi
is a business analytics service provided
by Microsoft that lets you visualize
your data and share insights it converts
data from different sources to build
interactive dashboards and bi reports as
you can see we have an Excel data about
sales using this data power bi helps you
build different charts and graphs to
visualize the data now that we have
understood what power bi is let us look
at the important features of power bi
first is power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a free software that you can
download and it allows you to build
reports by accessing data easily for
using power bi desktop you do not need
Advanced report designing or query
skills to build a report second as
already discussed power bi supports
stream analytics from Factory sensors to
social media sources power bi assists in
real-time analytics to make timely
decisions third support for multiple
data sources is one of the major
features of power bi you can access
various sources of data such as Excel
CSV SQL Server web files Etc to create
interactive visualizations and finally
custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs let
us jump into discussing the various
components of power bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mashup engine it
enables you to discover connect combine
and refine data sources to meet your
analysis need it can be downloaded as an
add-in for Excel or can be used as part
of power bi desktop second we have power
pivot power pivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or Dax to model simple and complex data
third we have power view Power view is a
technology that is available in Excel
SharePoint SQL server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to Life Next we have
power map Microsoft's power map for
Excel and power bi is a 3D data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on Bing maps in 3D
format from an Excel table or data model
in Excel then we have power bi desktop
power bi desktop is a development tool
for power query power pivot and Power
view with power bi desktop you have
everything under the same solution and
it is easier to develop bi and data
analysis experience finally we have
power Q and A the Q and A feature in
power bi lets you explore your data in
your own words it is the fastest way to
get an answer from your data using
natural language an example could be
what was the total sales last year once
you have built your data model and
deployed that into Power bi website
right then you can ask questions and get
answers easily now let's see what power
bi service is power bi service is the
software as a service part of power bi
it is also referred as power bi online
to access power bi service you need to
log into
app.powerbi.com now let me show you that
I'll go to Google
open a new tab and search for app dot
power bi
dot com
it's loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like I have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.power bi service you can
see I am logged in now under my
workspace if I go to dashboard here I've
created a finance dashboard you can see
the different charts and graphs I have
prepared and pinned it to the dashboard
so power bi service allows you to
connect to your data create reports and
dashboards and you can also ask
questions to your data as you can see in
this dashboard we have created some
charts and graphs so this is a tree map
there's a pie chart there's a bar graph
below you can see the line charts and
donut charts it tells you the total
sales that were made the total number of
units solds the sales by product sales
by country sales by segment and lots
more one of the key features of power bi
is creating dashboards from multiple
reports and data sets power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from multiple reports and
each report is based on one data set a
single page dashboard is known as a
canvas the visualizations you see on the
dashboard are called tiles these tiles
are pinned to the dashboard by report
designers now let me go back to my
dashboard so this is called a canvas and
each of these are called tiles so on the
top you can see we have three tiles now
let's understand how to create and
publish reports in power bi dashboards
power bi allows you to create different
reports on power bi desktop these
reports can be published on the power bi
dashboard using power bi service here
you can see there is a power bi report
created on power bi desktop if you click
on publish it will take you to the power
bi service where you can build a
dashboard here is the button for power
bi publish once you click on power bi
publish it will take you to the
dashboard so this is a single page power
bi dashboard on power bi service now
let's understand the power bi
architecture power bi architecture is a
service built on top of azure there are
multiple data sources that power bi can
connect to power bi desktop allows you
to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set Power bi
Gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for Windows
IOS and Android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how Meyer which is
one of United States largest Supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially Meyer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
Meyer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what Maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises SQL Server analysis Services
Cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near Real Time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real-time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside Meyer used
power bi to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
Meyer was behind the regional Trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 Maya Business
Leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and Empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track that data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical Hands-On demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data View and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables on the right you can
see the different visualizations that
you can build we'll quickly run through
all of these in our demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data Tab and choose Excel as my data
source I click on Excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if I go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has Fields
such as segment country in which the
Salesforce made the name of the product
the unit sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building a report
now I'll go to my report view so first
let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
Finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use Font Consolers
Center it will also add a background to
this we use blue color change it to
White
and
increase the size now let me first show
you how you can create a matrix I'll go
to visualizations and click on Matrix
let me resize it
from the datasheet tab I'll select sales
and drag on to values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so I'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to 20. similarly under values
we'll increase the size of the text to
20 as well we can also click on border
and choose the color of the Border we
take as Let It Be black so this is a
simple Matrix that we created which
shows the total number of sales that
were made similarly let me choose Matrix
once again now we'll drag on the units
sold onto values we'll continue with the
same drill under column headers We'll
add a background this time let's show
some other color and under values let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
again we will switch on Border we resize
a bit
so here we have two Matrix created for
our report the first Matrix shows us the
total sales that were made the second
Matrix shows you the total units that
were sold now let's move ahead and
create a simple bar chart so under
visualization I click on clustered
column chart
under this we'll drag the date column
onto access and the sales onto value let
me expand it so it shows you the sales
per year this is the sales that were
made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014. now
there's a drill down option which gives
you more granularity
this depicts the sales per quarter if I
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like sort by and sort
by sales so you can see October month
with the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments under visualization
I'll click on pie chart let me first
resize it
here
I'll drag the segment column onto the
legend and the sales column onto the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments government
segment made the highest number of sales
with 44.22 percent now let me add a
border to both the visualization I'll
click on the pie chart and go to the
format tab I'll switch on the border
similarly for the clustered column chart
I'll go to the format Tab and click on
Border let me resize a bit alright next
we'll create a very simple table that
will depict the total sales made by each
product so under visualizations I click
on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet I'll first drag
product onto values you can see the
different products and then sales just
below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here now let's do some formatting
under format tab I'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15. I'm expand
it also under column headers I'll
increase the text size to 15. then let
me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization I'll click
on map now I'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if I move the
map you can see the sales made in the
Europe region
let me resize it I'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations I'll
click on donut chart
and move this to the top now from the
data sheet I'll add profit onto the
values and segment
onto the legend
if I expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent let me resize
this and we'll add a border
okay in the final visualization I'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations I'll click on the tree
map let me expand it I'll drag sales
onto values and product onto group so
here you can see our tree map and the
sales made by each product you can see
now we have a report ready we have
created two separate canvas to visualize
our data now if you want to change the
color of these parts you can simply go
to the format Tab and under data colors
you can choose whichever color you want
in power bi desktop you have an option
to switch your theme this will make your
dashboard or the report look more
attractive so now we are under the
default mode Let's try out different
themes let's Frontier
temperature
solar which is a little yellowish the
one which I like is tidal I hope this
was helpful in making you understand the
basics of power bi and how it works you
learned the various features and the
components of power bi and looked at the
architecture of RBI finally you saw a
demo to create a report using Finance
data set in our previous video on what
is power bi we had learned the basics of
power bi its features and components the
architecture of power bi followed by a
demo in this video we will learn what
power bi dashboard is we'll understand
how to create different reports in power
bi desktop then you will publish a
dashboard onto power bi service and
finally you'll derive insights from the
dashboard now let's understand what
power bi dashboard is power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story here on the screen you can see
there's a dashboard which has been
published on power bi service there are
multiple charts and graphs that you can
see the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualization you see on the dashboard
are called tiles and each of these tiles
are pinned to the dashboard by report
designers today we'll be covering the
following dashboard that you see on the
screen it will be a three page report
where we will be analyzing the
superstore sample data as you can see
there are three tabs now let me move
over to our data set so our Superstore
sample data set is in the form of an
Excel file you can see there are
multiple columns you can see there's
order date shipment date the mode of
shipment customers first name and last
name the segment to which the customer
belong to country of the customer the
city state and if you go towards the end
you can see that the different product
names the sales quantity sold discount
and the profit so the report that you
see here and the one which we are going
to create might vary a little in terms
of the color formatting and the spacing
so you need not worry about that now let
me go ahead and bring up a new workspace
so I'll go to file click on new this
will take some time to bring up our new
workspace now it will ask you for trying
the free version or if you want you can
go ahead and sign in I'll just close
this so here is our new workspace before
creating the dashboard we need to make
some changes to our Superstore data set
using the features of power bi desktop
first we'll extract the year month and
quarter values from the order date
column I'll go to get data tab click on
Excel as my source I'll locate my file
it's on desktop click on open this might
take some time to load the data set I'll
select the orders sheet you can see the
preview of our data here I'll go ahead
and click on load this will take some
time to load the data set on to power bi
desktop I think we have successfully
loaded our data set you can check that
by going to the data tab so here is our
data set first let's make some changes
in the format of the order date and the
shipment date I'll click on the order
date under the modeling tab
we have this data type and the format
I'll click on the drill down option
and the date and time now let's choose
the first one which is in the format of
ddmm yyy
and click on it
as you can see our order date column has
been changed to that particular format
similarly I'll select the ship date
column
go to the format option under date and
time I click on the first one
here you can see even the ship date
column has been changed to that
particular format now let's extract the
month values from the order date column
to do that right click on the order date
column
select new column
so this will create a new column if you
go to the end so there's a new column
rename this column as month and since we
want the month value from the order date
column I'll search for order date
dot since I want the month I'll select
month if I hit enter
it will give me the month values from
the order date column
similarly if you want to get the quarter
values from the order date right click
select new column
rename the column as quarter
[Music]
then choose the order date column
followed by the quarter name hit enter
so you can see you have a quarter column
and it has all the values of the quarter
to which the date belongs to now let me
go ahead and create one more column
this time we'll create a new column for
the order year this time we'll extract
the order year values so let me rename
it as year we'll continue with the same
procedure I look for the order date and
then select the year
hit enter
so it gives you only the EO values on
which the order was placed
now let's find which day of the week was
the order placed so we need to use the
weekday function and give the order
data's parameter followed by which day
you want the week to start with I'll
show you how to do that so I'll click on
order date
then select new column
let's rename this column as day of week
I'll use the weekday function of power
bi you can hit tab to finish I look for
my order date column
comma
I'll choose 2 here since I want my week
to start with Monday and end on a Sunday
hit enter
so you can see we have the day of the
week column
so the idea to create this day of V
column is to find out if the order was
placed on a weekday or a weekend now let
me go ahead and create one more new
column
let's name this column as
weekday
or a weekend
I'll use an if clause
and pass in my parameters for logical
test I'll use the day of the week column
so I'll search for orders
and then look for day of week if this
day of the week is equal to 6 which
means if it's a Saturday or I'm using
the or operator
at the day of week is a Sunday that is 7
then it's a weekend
else it's a weekday
and close the bracket hit enter so you
can see we have our weekday and weekend
column so moving ahead another thing we
can do is we can find the total number
of days it took for the shipment of the
product this can be done using the
dative function of power bi so let me
show you how you can do that I'll click
on any column right click go to new
column let's rename the column as
days for shipment then I'll use the date
div function
I'll give my starting date which is the
order date so I'll search for
order date
followed by the second date will be our
shipment date which is ship date and the
day
I'll hit enter
so you can see here it gives us the
total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product now let's create
a full name column where we will
concatenate the first name and the last
name of the customer let me go ahead and
do that
I'll create a new column
let me rename the column as full name
then I'll take the first name
from the orders table use the Amber send
followed by a space using inverted
commas followed by another Ampersand and
the last name
I hit enter
you can see we have a full name column
if you go back so there were two columns
in the name of first name and last name
now we have merged both the columns into
a single column named full name and you
can see the first name space and the
last name now let me give the sales
column
a currency value so I'll select the
sales column
here
under General
if I go to currency I can see there are
multiple currency symbols
choose whatever you want for this video
I'll take dollar English United States
you can see our sales column is now
represented by a dollar value similarly
let me make some changes to the profit
column as you can see there are multiple
decimal values for each profit so let's
standardize it
so I'll select the profit column
and this is where you can standardize it
now it's Auto so let me make it two
decimal places
so our data is ready now let's go to the
report View and start building our
reports
before that
under the model view you can see the new
columns that we had created you can see
there's weekday weekend this year
this quarter column month column
the same you can see under the report
view as well
under fields
you can see these are the columns that
we created days of shipment day of week
quarter
month weekday or weekend and year now we
are under the report view first let me
go ahead and create a text box
so under the Home tab you have the text
box
I'll select that
let me stretch it a bit
we'll give a title
sales
dashboard I'll select this and increase
the size to
let's say 28 we make it bold
and Center align it also under the
visualizations tab under background
we'll add a background color to this
text box let me select this blue color
and let me make
the font as white
so now we have our title ready
so under General you can decrease the
height of the text box let me make it as
70.
first let us create a new card from the
visualizations panel so under
visualizations there is an option to
create new card I'll click on it
let me resize
I'll move it to the top
we'll see the total amount of sales all
the total revenue that was generated
from the sales after selecting the card
I'll choose sales onto fields
so here you can see it gives you the
total sales that were made so which is
nearly 2.3 million dollars
if I go to the format tab under data
label
let me switch on the border under title
you can give a new title for example
total
Revenue hit enter
now you can
increase the text size to say 15 and
Center Line it you can also change the
color of the sales value so under data
label under colors you can choose
whichever color you want
similarly let's create one more card to
find the total number of units that were
sold I'll copy the same card
Ctrl C Ctrl V
I'll move it a little below
now I'll remove the sales column
from the fields and add the quantity
column onto fields
again
under title I'll edit this title as
total
quantity sold
let me create one more card
where we will see the total amount of
profit that were made I'll select this
I'll remove the quantity column
and add profit
under the format tab
under title
I'll make this as
total
profit
hit enter
stretch it a bit so that you can see the
total amount of profit that were made
now
let me add a slicer
wherein
will have the order date column
so I'll add the order date column onto
fields
so you can see here we have the order
date column and
under slicer header let me increase the
text size
to 15
and
let's switch on the border
you can also give a title to the slicer
so under the format tab to go to title
switch it on
and we'll give a title text as
slicer by
order
date
scroll down I'll Center align it and
increase the text size to 15.
now if you want you can also change the
date colors
to Blue so under date inputs then go to
font color and select any blue color
now let's create a line and stacked
column chart to visualize sales and
profit by each year each month and each
quarter so from the visualizations tab
let me select line and stack column
chart
I'll resize this
after that let me add the order date
column onto the shared axis
we'll drag the sales onto column values
and underline values I'll take the
profit column
so here you can see we have the sales
and profit by each year
the bars represent the seals and this
line represents the profit it made for
each year let me go to the format tab
and
make some changes to the data colors let
the color of the profit remain the same
but the bars I'll choose a custom color
give a hexadecimal value like
hit enter
so we have successfully changed the
color of the bars power bi has an
interesting feature where you can drill
down the seals by each year each month
each quarter or by days so let me show
you so on the top it shows you go to the
next level in the hierarchy so if I
click on this here you can see the sales
and the profit that were made for each
quarter in every year
quarter four for every year with the
highest amount of sales and the profit
similarly if I drill down further you
can see let me expand it you can see by
month this is for each month
over all the years how much sales were
made
you can check November month give us the
highest amount of sales and December
month gave us the highest amount of
profit
similarly you can still go to the next
hierarchy here you can see
the sales and the profit made for each
day over all the years so day 17 meet
the highest amount of sales
and day 23 gave us the highest amount of
profit if you see the lowest sales and
the profit you can see order date 25
gave us the lowest amount of profit
and similarly you can see day 29 gave us
the lowest amount of sales
now you can also go to the format tab
and switch on the data labels
so you can see here in 2014 we got
nearly 49.5 K profit and nearly 0.48
million dollar sales similarly in 2015
we had nearly 61.6 K profit and 0.47
million sales and so on
now let me go ahead to the format Tab
and
switch on the border let me now create a
clustered column chart for sales by year
and quarter so from the visualizations
let's select clustered column chart let
me resize this a bit
and under access
will add the year column
so I'll drag here onto axis under Legend
I'll take the quarter column
and under values I'll choose sales
so you can see here the sales that were
made under each quarter for each year
this picture clearly sees quarter four
for every year Meet the highest amount
of sales and quarter one
made the lowest
let me go to the format tab
and
I'll go to the data colors let's change
the colors for each of these quarters
we'll be using hexadecimal values so
under custom colors for quarter one
let me select hexadecimal value as
follows so for example PF D6 D9
similarly for Quarter Two
I'll select 6D 9 bs6
for quarter three
and finally for quarter four
I choose a little darker color
so here is how our clustered column
chart looks like and we can see the
sales by year and quarter
now let me go ahead and
let's add a border now we'll analyze the
seals by each state so for that we will
use field map so I'll click on field map
let me resize it
now let me add the state column onto
location
and the tooltips I'll
add the sales column
let me expand it so you can see here we
have the map which shows the sales by
each state
now let's do some color formatting to
this
I'll go to the format tab click on ADD
colors
and blue is the default color there is
an additional option
where you can use conditional formatting
so I'll use that so it gives you the
option to choose your color between
maximum value and the minimum value you
can also choose this diverging option
where you get a center value or a mid
value as well now for the minimum value
I'll choose a color again I'll use a
custom color it will be similar to a
green color
hit okay then
let's use some orange color for the mid
value range for example EB
and similarly for the maximum value
we'll use a little darker color which
looks similar to red
click enter so now we have defined our
color scheme
let's click on OK
let's zoom out so you can see the states
which are in green color meet the lowest
amount of sales while those which are in
orange or in red meet the highest amount
of sales so in this example you can see
California had the highest amount of
sales similarly New York is next is just
below California with the amount of
sales followed by Texas I'll go back
let me also
add a border to this similarly you can
also select the profit column or the
unit sold column to see the units or the
profit that were sold by each state
so let me now go ahead and create a
donut chart in the donut chart we'll
analyze the sales and profit by each
segment
so under visualizations I click on donor
chart
so under Legend I'll add the segment
column
under values I'll take the sales column
and
we also want the profit so I'll take
The Profit column onto tooltips
so you can see we have a donut chart
prepared and you can see the sales and
profit by each segment
let me expand this the donut chart
indicates consumer segment made the
highest amount of sales and profit while
home office segment made the lowest
I'll go back
let me go to the format tab
and we'll make some formatting to our
data
let's change the color of all the
segments
choose custom color
let's give a color
coding as
1558c
similarly we change
the color for corporate segment as well
let's take a gray color
and finally we'll change the color for
home office as well
I'll also switch on the border
so we have our donor chart prepared now
let's move ahead and create a pie chart
to analyze the profit and sales by each
category of products so under
visualizations I'll select pie chart
I'll drag the category column onto
Legend
under values I'll take the profit column
and under tooltips I'll take the sales
column
so you can see we have a simple pie
chart that tells you the profit and the
sales that were made by each category
as it's evident category technology made
the highest amount of sales and profit
while Furniture category made the lowest
amount of profit and sales
I'll go back
under format I'll change the data Colors
Let's go ahead and do that
I'll use custom colors and give
hexadecimal color value
similarly for office supplies
I'll take another hexadecimal value
and finally we'll change the color of
the furniture category
also
let's give a border
so we have our pie chart prepared that
tells you the profit and sales by each
category of products now we are done
with our first sales dashboard so I can
go ahead
and rename
this tab as
overall sales
next we are going to analyze the sales
profit quantity sold and all of these
by taking region and the state as
filters so we'll continue with the same
Trail first I'll create a text box
so under home menu I'll go to text box
I'll stretch this
I'll give a title to this page for
example region
and
state
level analysis
let me make it bold
and
I'll increase the size to 28
make it Center aligned
will make the text
as white
and
the visualizations
let's give a background color
I choose this blue color
so let me go ahead and create three
slicers a region slicer a state slicer
and a ear slicer so under visualizations
I'll click on slicer
let me resize
move it on top
and
for region slicer I need to add region
onto fields
so you can see we have a region filter
now
let's do some formatting to this
under slicer header
let me make the font color
white and
let's give a background
let's say blue
and let me increase the text size to
say 15.
you can also choose a font family
let's go for calibri
and
you can increase this size
of the items let's increase the text
size
to
say 15.
and
let's give a border
so now you have the region slicer ready
let me copy paste this
next
we'll create the state slicer so I'll
remove region from here and add
State onto the field
you can see we have the state slicer
ready similarly
you can also go ahead
and create a year slicer
where you can analyze the sales and
profit or quantity by year
I'll remove State from here
and
I'll drag the ear column onto field
you can see we have all the four years
from 2014 to 2017. so sometimes it might
be difficult for you to scroll through
all the values present in a slicer for
example
in the state slicer
you can see there are multiple States
and if you want to filter your report by
a particular State you have to always
scroll down or scroll up and check
manually where the state is so power bi
gives you this feature where you can use
the search option so if I click on this
you can see there's a search option
select that so now
in the search bar you can search for any
state you are looking for for example if
you want to search for California state
you can just type on California so you
have just type Cal and it shows me
California that's an important feature
that power bi gives you
so let me now go ahead and create a
simple table where we will see the
quantity and the profit made in each
City so under visualizations I'll select
tables
let me resize this
so under values first I'll add the city
column
followed by
the quantity column
and
The Profit column
let's do some formatting
so under column headers
let me change the font color to white
and let's add a background
let me increase the
text size also
let's make it 15.
similarly if you scroll down under
values
let's increase the text size
to 15 as well
and
let's choose the font family let's take
consoles
so here
you can see all the cities
the quantity
sold in each City and the profit that
was made in each of these cities
now let me add a border to this
foreign
so now you can filter each of these
cities by region or by state
for example if I choose Central
as my region
it will give you all the cities that lie
in the central region
similarly
you can also search for any state for
example I am taking Minnesota
so under Minnesota you can see all the
cities and the quantity as well as the
profits made
let me now uncheck the filters now let
me go ahead and filter this table
in terms of profit so I'll sort by
profit
you can see
we have our cities sorted in terms of
profit
so New York City made the highest amount
of profit followed by Los Angeles and
Seattle below you can see the total
units that were sold and the total
profit that was made from all the cities
so you can also filter down the quantity
sold and the profit made by each year as
well as by region and State
so let's see suppose I am choosing
East as the region
so under East it tells you the states
that are present
let's
go for Delaware
and let's select 2016 as my year
so you can see
the cities that lie under delivery state
and the quantity as well as the profit
the made in 2016. similarly let's select
Massachusetts as the state and let's
go for another year for example 2017
you can see all the cities that are
present under Massachusetts the quantity
sold and the profit that was made below
you can see the total quantity and the
profit
let me uncheck all these
now moving ahead let's analyze the sales
by each state and the category of
product for this
will create a clustered bar chart so
under visualizations I'll select
clustered bar chart let me resize a bit
under axis
I'll take the state column
I'll take category onto Legend
and under values
I'll put the sales column
so you can see here
we have the sales for each category
under each state
for example California state made the
highest amount of sales under technology
category and it made the lowest amount
of sales under office supplies
if I scroll down you can see all the
states
and the sales they made
for each category
I'll go back to the report
now let's use some filters
you can filter here for example if I
want to check
the sales by each state and category for
2015 I can just
click on 2015
and it will tell you the sales that were
made
now let's do some formatting to this bar
chart
I'll change the colors for each of the
categories
similarly we change the color for office
supplies
and finally for the technology
so now we have our bar chart ready
moving on now let me add a border to
this bar chart
okay
so now that we have seen our sales by
state and category let's now check the
profit by year and category for that
we'll create an area chart
I'll resize this chart
now
under access
I'll take the year column
under Legend
I'll take the category column
and
and the values
I'll take profit
so we have our area chart that depicts
The Profit by each year and the category
to which the product belong to
I'll go to the format Tab and under data
colors
I'll choose some colors
let's change Furniture to this blue
color
I'll take office supplies a red color
and Technology I'll use a green color
so now you can use the filters
for example you can check the profit
that was made by each year and category
under east region
so you can see here
in 2017 technology meet the highest
amount of profit while furniture at the
lowest
similarly
let's
check for South Region
so you can see in south region in 2016
technology meet the highest amount of
profit and
furniture made the lowest in 2017 office
supplies made the highest amount of
profit and Furniture was the lowest
I'll uncheck this South Region filter
similarly you can also see the sales by
each state so under State slicer you can
choose whichever State you want and
check the profit it made by that year or
category
for example I'll choose connect ticket
so you can see the profit Connecticut
state made in each of these years
I'll uncheck it
let us move ahead and now let's see
profit that was made and the quantity
that was sold by each category and
subcategory of the product so for this
I'll choose the line and cluster column
chart so I'll select from the
visualizations now
under shared access
I'll select the category column under
column series I'll take the subcategory
column
under column values
I'll choose profit
and
I'll choose quantity
under the tooltips
so now you can see
The Profit that was made under each
category and the subcategory
for technology category copiers
subcategory meet the highest amount of
profit the quantity sold was 234.
similarly
if you check for furniture category
we didn't make any profit for table
subcategory
and as well as for bookcases
under office supplies paper subcategory
meet the highest amount of profit
now let me go ahead and add a border to
this
fine
moving ahead now we will see the sales
by each segment for that let's create a
funnel so from visualizations I'll take
the
funnel and
I'll drag
segment onto group
and the sales column onto values
so you can see here
the sales that were made by each segment
this picture clearly depicts that
consumer segment with the highest amount
of sales next was corporate and then
home office
now
let's do some color formatting so the
default color is this blue
I'll click on so all
now we'll give individual colors to each
of the segments
using custom color
let's give a hexadecimal value
similarly we'll change the color for the
corporate segment
and finally for the home office segment
now let me go ahead and give a border to
it
so if you want to analyze the seals by
segment and for a particular region or
state or any particular year you can do
that so let's select
for each region
and
let's take New Jersey as the state
for year 2014 suppose
so you can see here corporate segment
meet the highest amount of sales
followed by consumer and home office
let me uncheck
these filters
so our second report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity profit at
Region level state level and by year so
I can rename this
as
a region and State
next we will analyze the sales quantity
profit in terms of categories and
subcategory of products so let me first
copy this text box
and create a new tab
I'll paste that text box here and
change the title to
say
category
and
sub category level analysis
first
we'll create a slicer
where we'll take
the category as filter
so if I want I can directly copy it
from my previous tab
and change the fields so let me copy
this
and paste it here
I'll sync it
and let me remove the region field and
add
category onto the field
so you can see
we have the three categories here
let me copy paste this again and
let me take the subcategory now
so I'll select this
and
I'll track subcategory onto the field so
here you can see we have all the
subcategories and above we have the
categories
let me resize this a bit
with that now let's analyze the sales
and profit by region and segment
to do this we'll use a tree map so let's
see how you can build a tree map under
visualizations I have tree map let me
select it
and move it to the top
and expand it a bit
now
under group
I'll select region column
and the details I'll take
segment
I'll take the sales column under values
and let's take profit
on to tooltips
so if I expand this
you can see the sales and profit by each
region and segment for example in the
west region you have consumer corporate
and home office
as the segments and you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of sales
and profit while home office made the
lowest amount of sales and profit
similarly you can check for the other
regions as well
now
let's give a border to this pre-map and
under data colors let me change the
color of the regions
scroll down
custom color let me let me choose my own
color
let's take this as a gray color
and finally
for the best region
so now you can select individual
categories and sub categories to check
the sales and profit by region and
segment for example
if I select Furniture as my category
you can see the changes that were made
to the tree map
you can also select office supplies and
see
how the sales and profit changes
similarly you can also go ahead and
select whatever subcategories you want
and then check the sales and profit by
region and segment with that let me now
create a pie chart
to see the quantity and the sales by
each segment
so I'll go and select a pie chart
let me resize this
if you want you can increase the size of
this tree map also
so let me go ahead
and select segment onto the legend
under values I'll take quantity
and
sales under tooltips
so this pie chart
depicts the quantity and the sales that
were made by each segment as you can see
consumer segment meet the highest amount
of sales and had the highest quantity
sold
while home office had the least number
of quantities sold and the least number
of sales
let's add a border
and
change the data colors
similarly I'll change the color for the
corporate segment let's make this
green
and home office
I'll take the following color
move this a little to the right
now let's build a scatter plot to
analyze the sales quantity and profit by
each subcategory
so under visualizations
I'll select scatter plot I'll resize
this
so I'll add
sub category onto Legend
then I'll add sales onto the x-axis
quantity sold onto the y-axis
and under size
will take the profit column
if I expand this
you can see the sales quantity and the
profit that was made for each
subcategory of products you can see here
subcategory phone has given us a
significant amount of sales with less
number of quantities sold and it has
given us a good amount of profit also
similarly subcategory shares has also
given us good amount of sales with close
to 2356 quantities sold and a good
amount of profit if you see this one
which is subcategory paper it gave us
less amount of sales with more
quantities sold while it gave us good
amount of profit though so you may
promote phones or for example chairs to
sell more since it gives you more amount
of profit with less quantity sold
let's add a border to this
you can use the category filter suppose
if I choose for furniture
and expand this
you can see
under Furniture subcategory Furnishings
give us the lowest amount of sales with
the highest number of quantities sold
but it gave us a decent amount of profit
subcategory tables give us a decent
amount of sales with lesser number of
quantities sold but didn't give us any
profit
subcategory chairs give us the highest
amount of sales and also the profit
I'll uncheck this
let's now create a line chart where we
can see the profit by each year and
quarter so under visualizations
I'll select line chart
let me resize this
so under access
I'll take here
under Legend
I'll take the quarter column
and under values
I'll take the profit column
so now you can see
The Profit that was made
each year and the lines depict each
quarter
so if you check for 2014 quarter four
meet the highest amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit while quarter 1 made the lowest
amount of profit similarly if you see
for 2016 you can see
quarter four meet the highest amount of
profit
while quarter One Meet the lowest
if you check for 2017 you see quarter
three and quarter four almost meet the
same amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit
I go back
now you can filter these by categories
also suppose if I see for technology
you can check the amount of profit that
was made in each year and in each
quarter for technology category
let's add a border to this
likewise we'll now create another line
chart that will depict the sales by each
year and quarter
so let me copy paste this
I'll drag this to the right
now I'll remove
profit from values and add sales
let me uncheck this also
so here you can see we have the sales by
each year and quarter
now if you see for 2014 again quarter 4
made the highest amount of sales and
quarter 1 in 2014 made the lowest
you will see for 2016 you can see 2016
also quarter for me the highest amount
of sales and quarter one made the lowest
I'll go back
so our final report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity sold the
profit at category and subcategory level
I can go ahead and rename this as
category
and subcategory
let me save this now if you want
you can also filter it by subcategories
for example if I select
chairs as my subcategory
so for chairs you can see the sales that
was made by each year in quarter
so in 2017 quarter four made the highest
amount of seals while quarter one made
the lowest amount of sales for cheers
similarly
you can select other subcategories also
for example
let me take
some other category like
machines
let's see the profit now
so for machine subcategory you can see
in 2014 quarter four meet the highest
amount of profit while
quarter 3
meet the lowest amount of profit
now if you check for 2015 you can see
quarter three meet the highest amount of
profit in shares while quarter 1 made
the lowest amount of profit
let's uncheck this
so now we are almost done building a
report using the superstore sample data
set
so we have our three reports ready you
can see the first one was overall sales
the second report we created
by taking region State and the year as
filters so we had a region and state
level analysis and finally we analyzed
the sales quantity and the profit sold
by category and subcategory so I have
arranged all these graphs and charts so
that it looks little better now let me
go to this publish option on the top so
that we can publish this report onto the
power bi dashboard
so I'll click on publish
I'll save it
you can select the destination here I
have only one destination which is my
workspace so I'll choose it and select
so there you go publishing to power bi
it was successful
I'll close it
and let me move to my power bi service
I'll refresh it for once
so under my workspace
you can see we have the dashboard report
So Below you can see there are three
tabs that we created the first one is
overall sales
the second one he seals by region the
third one is by category and subcategory
now
to put this reports onto the dashboard I
need to pin each one of these
visualizations
so
let me pin one by one
so it asks where would you want to pin
it to I'll select the existing dashboard
or better let's create a new dashboard
let's say
power bi
dashboard
spin it
close this
similarly let's spin the remaining ones
I'll select power bi dashboard again pin
it
let's spin everything
so this slicer you can't pin it
let's do the remaining ones
same will do for the donor chart
as well as
for the pie chart
now
if I go to
my dashboards
and select power bi dashboard
you can see
we have a one page
dashboard here
you can resize all the charts and graphs
let me resize it
and move it to the top
so we have our first canvas here which
tells you the overall sales the profit
and the units that were sold over
different states different segments and
by categories so one of the important
feature that power bi service gives you
is that you can ask questions about your
data and it will tell you what the exact
solution is for example you can see here
you have a field where you can ask
questions so for example if I type
total sales
and hit enter
so it tells you the total amount of
sales that were made which is 2.3
million dollars similarly if I want to
find out the total
profit I can search for it here
hit enter
it will give you the exact amount of
profit that was made let's do something
else for example if you want
total
profit
by
say here
I'll hit enter it gives you a nice line
chart where you can see the total profit
that was made over all the four years
next suppose I searched for total
quantity
sold
by
segment
see it gives me a bar chart where you
can see the total quantity that was sold
and it gives you a list of options where
you can find out the total quantity that
was sold by city state order ID first
name last name and many others so
consumer segment had the highest
quantity sold
let's see it's for something else for
example if you want
the total
sales by
say subcategory
I'll choose the first one see you have
all the subcategories and the total
sales that they made so it's a very
interesting feature that power bi gives
you
go back
now if you want
you can go to the report menu
and if you want you can pin the other
visualizations as well
so another important feature about power
bi dashboard is that you can derive
insights from the visualization for
example
if I click on these dots there's an
option you find view insights I'll
select it
so on the right you can see Power bi has
itself given us some insights from the
data and the visualizations we have made
you can see sales by year and quarter
the sales by day of week and quarter
sales by shipment mode where you can see
the standard classic Mode made the
highest amount of sales
you can also see the sales and count of
City by year
and many more
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video a
team will share the files via email now
let's begin by understanding what is a
dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating a dashboards we'll
be using a sample sales data set let me
show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo so this data set
was actually generated using a simulator
and is completely random it was not
validated though we have applied certain
transformations to the data using power
query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa this North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online
next we have the order priority column
now here C stands for critical
then we have H which is for high
priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of units sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this I'll click on a cell in my data set
and then I'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is I'll drag my order here
column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we'll label our
x-axis and y axis so here under x axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move a bit
all right now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99 000 I'll put it in the format
of millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all red you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I just click ok so that my PO table is
placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go so we have our
next pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the sub-Saharan African region
in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa made the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly Dropped In 2012. then in
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
by
year end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table let's create our pivot chart so
I'll go to recommended charts and if you
see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add data labels so I'll click
on data labels here okay so these are
the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
and click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and here you have pie
chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it and from here I'll remove the
field buttons
and I also don't need the legend so I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I'll click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now let's create our horizontal bar
chart I'll go to insert click on pivot
table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names we have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India there's Jamaica Italy and
all the way to the bottom if you go we
have New Zealand this Netherlands
Philippines Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our po chart so I'll go to insert
and select recommended charts
from here I'm going to select the column
chart you can see the preview here and
let me click on OK
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style 6 okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my PO table on a new worksheet
and this time I'm going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies meet
the highest amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I have selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
foreign
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Center Line at
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see shape format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and I'll
also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click and go to format
chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline you see this so we have our
total revenue by year which is a line
chart and this is completely transparent
now now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box
so I'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so I'll click on illustrations and here
I'll choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape here
I'll increase the transparency let's
keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard
so I've added a few logos for each of
the charts you can see the logos here so
for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year in region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline or if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab here also you
have insert slicer and timeline option
so I'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country
region
and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slices we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this go to report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
I'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
go to report connections and then I'll
select all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
this chart represents the revenue that
was generated in each of the countries
only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channels so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select offline you can see the values
have changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we'll move to our data sheet and
start creating your pivot tables and po
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I'm going to create a line
chart to visualize the profit for each
year
so I'll drag my
total profit column two values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay and if you want you
can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the row labels as
countries
and then
I'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
and Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so
my new range
will be my original po table that I had
created
I'll go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here now based on
this pivot table let me create my PO
chart so I'll go to recommended charts
and I'm going to create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly in year 2012 the
Online Profit was actually higher than
the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here and click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons let me now remove the legend as
well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
by type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's say C which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I am going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my pivot
table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building our dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
will continue with the previous drill
so first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustrations
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see I have brought my
Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step let me now go
ahead and edit the title so this is
actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard so
let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I've also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid lines
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I'm going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
by labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
have also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I am going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so I've
selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is view table number 10
if I click on OK similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so I right click go to
report connections
here I'll
choose all my Pivot tables which are
based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well I'll go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017 or
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
no if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer let me just bring
this to the middle and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just bring this to the front so that you
can see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item meet the highest
amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say I want to
know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually
not millions that should be in K that is
Thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k n
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables and
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing you can also
change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see our
chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the text also change a bit you can
see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I am going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right
so in this demo we saw how to create a
revenue dashboard so we created line
charts this combo chart pie chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learned how to
add slicers and connected to different
pivot tables and we filtered our data to
see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more and with that we have
reached the end of day 4 of our data
science week on day 5 we are going to
learn about machine learning for data
science thank you all for watching
today's live session I hope it is useful
and informative see you tomorrow thanks
again and keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here